Happy duty!
Thank you so much for the Tony Captain!
Thank you!
Wow, it's been so long since I last streamed!
Definitely for me it was not...
20 minutes ago!
Not at all!
I totally didn't get changed in that time.
We missed you!
Wow.
You guys are too much.
Hishashiburi!
You missed me?
You missed me!
Today is a collab!
So, it'll be me.
I'm going in order of people on the thumbnail.
Oymo!
Mogu!
Dust go.
They are... they are...
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna click out of the game and it's gonna stop the
music.
They are in Discord right now, so I should probably join.
I should probably stop being a little introvert and talking
to you guys.
Are we there yet?
So I'm going to join them.
Um, I'm coming.
I'm going to tell them and be like, Oh, let me, let me, let
me socializing.
Whoa, yeah.
It's my first time collabing with everybody, but I've been
friends with everybody for quite a long time.
funny that it's our first time collabing like actually me
and Dusko like we hang out very not I wouldn't say often but
like if we're in the same place together we hang out
together so like I see her at many conventions and events
and we've gone to Disney together and stuff so two ghosts in
one stream I know!
And Vogue was a ghost we're extra haunted yeah yeah So,
yeah, I'm going to go, I'm going to join now.
Bye, everybody.
Oh, why did Oimo say no?
I don't think Oimo wants to collab with me.
I think she hates me.
I'm coming in anyway.
Oh, my God.
We should run.
Run, run, run, run.
Thank you, Aklaan, Mint Slime.
Me, howdy, Mint.
Me, howdy.
What's going on?
What's happening?
I think Oimo's about to pass away.
Can you resurrect her?
Can you give her mouth to mouth, please?
Why is she about to pass away?
Wait.
Because you walked in the room.
You just have to affect the people.
Oimo is not in the call.
She doesn't recognize my existence.
This is great.
She's going great.
It's going awesome.
This is already going so great.
She doesn't hear me.
I'm gonna...
No, I can hear you.
I can hear you.
Just why aren't you in the Discord?
Oh my gosh, is that Mogu wants to play with me?
Oh my god, Carol!
Oh my god!
No!
Wait, the invite disappeared.
I didn't- Wait, you can change their skin color?
Wait, let me share my screen.
This is insane.
Oh wait, I can hear you in the game, huh?
down in the game.
I think so.
Send me another invite, please.
Wait, why can I...
Why can't I send it?
Dusty, you can use it in the invite.
Yeah, it'll work.
Oh.
It's like great outfit.
Why?
Why game hate me?
Does the audio doubled right now?
Yes.
Oh, it says that...
Are we gonna talk in the game?
It says she's in the game.
Do you want to talk in the game or do you want to talk in
the game?
talk here.
Talking real live.
Talking the game or talking real live.
Oh, my mic is... I can turn on push to talk or whatever.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, give, give.
I just turned off the audio.
Oh, you guys want to be...
I'm going to be old.
I'm going to be an old dude.
Oh, my God.
This guy is shaking.
I've got Arthur right.
Uh-oh.
Sorry.
The invite is not working.
Wait, I'm going to quit the game and restart the game.
It says, yeah, because it says that you're in here.
It does?
Oh, does it?
Oh, maybe I should.
Oh, no.
And then now it's gone.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Let me try.
Wait, hold up.
How did you guys switch your avatar?
I'm still listening.
I've always been.
It's like the left and right on the bottom of your
character.
Like the arrows.
The less than greater than.
You went to college.
Did I?
Did you?
I did.
I certainly did.
There's in-game.
Let me actually, let me see if it's the game registered that
I bought.
Hold up.
I forgot to cover my screen.
Maybe it's me.
Maybe I'm gonna, should I leave?
Oh, it's...
Did I kick everyone out?
Yeah, I kicked everyone out.
No!
Oops!
Okay, um, should I...
Should I try hosting or does someone else want to try
hosting and inviting everyone?
Let me try.
Would that work?
Yes.
Okay, I'm able to make a- Okay.
I think you just- Oh, joy.
Ah!
Oh!
What the hell?
Here!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh, I changed me.
Oh, I have to be an old lady.
Why- oh, you're the- You're the driver, Duska!
Oh god!
You can tell that to Babo.
He will lose his mind!
Wait!
He says I'm terrible at driving.
Who's the best driver here?
How many of us can drive?
I can drive!
I can drive?
Oh, it's only me?
Oh, yeah, you're Echo, you're Double.
Am I?
Double-oo.
Yeah, Double-oo.
Oh my god, you're so cute.
Get in the car, shiny!
Wait, is it only me that's double-ing?
Am I doubled?
Yes.
I am?
Oh, what?
Oh, no, I think...
Mogus doubled?
Am I doubled now?
Oh, one at a time.
Oh.
Okay, no, the myth is good.
Yippee!
Can you hear me, Sunny?
Peanut climbs.
Okay, you're good.
I don't hear you.
How do you change your character?
I can't with the arrow keys I don't have the paid version of
that way.
Oh, that's probably why.
Oh my god, you look like me Man paid a win.
I made a win You've got to be guy green shirt.
I want to be a little grandma grandpa.
You don't you look like an emo kid Do I that's how I look
like a real one You know what I look like?
Yeah!
Am I emo?
Oh, oh, no!
What's your my space, Katie?
Krosky Koon.
Would I be in your top five?
Yes, always.
We're gonna put Babo second.
Actually, we're gonna put him fifth.
Wait, where's me?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm like number nine.
No!
I'll take it.
Number nine.
Nine for baka.
Foot lettuce.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That's two very different brain rods.
Foot lettuce.
Oh my god.
Only the boomer otaku know the nine.
It's true.
The nine with the circle.
Yeah.
I bet Mogu doesn't know this.
Oh wait.
You can be a grandma if you press the middle button, Mogu.
Middle button.
If you want to drive.
You know what?
Wait, what?
While passenger while driving.
While I'm not a passenger though.
Whenever the grandma opens her mouth, it's like really
terrifying.
It's like...
Ah!
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's so scary.
Okay, we can customize the car.
You can customize the car?
Yeah.
Oh, never mind.
Don't let me customize the car.
You lied to me, kid.
You give me these options.
Ah.
Lame.
Okay, it says level select.
Oh, we can play Evening at Grandma's or Neil Peel's Deals on
Wheels.
Has anyone played this game?
Do we know what we're doing?
I got no idea.
I think that's the best part, right?
Yeah, we gotta discover how to drive together.
Yeah!
Okay, you guys ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Let's try this out.
Oh, it's spooky.
Oh, my God.
What?
What are we hearing?
What the heck?
Is that you?
Is that me?
Instead of rushing us out the door, Grandma and Grandpa had
us all crowded around the TV.
Oh my gosh, it's so scary.
They'd heard about it, Bingo Hall.
They were in awe.
A sweaty local car salesman was blowing their minds with his
latest no-catch government-funded offer.
Oh, mucho texto.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Holy crap!
Jesus, why aren't you dyslexic to read this?
Oh, who skipped it?
Oh my god, skipped it!
I think I accidentally skipped it.
I'll go down.
That's okay.
Right, right, right, space.
Oh, I'm- it's so wobbly.
I'm gonna get so sick.
I'm so- I'm so old.
Who's next to me?
Who are you?
Oh, I'm in the middle.
I'm in the middle seat.
You're in the middle?
Hi!
This is me, so neat.
Are you guys all in the back?
Oh, I guess I'm driving.
Yeah, you're driving.
grandma i can't see it go grandma can you go in the mix tape
i can't see anything grandma i want to listen to the mix
tape as brittany's here i'm getting car sick okay oh geez oh
god wait i can wait i just grabbed this tape from you but
now i can't get rid of this tape what do i do with this oh i
can change the ac it's yeah it's blasted grandma blast it
Okay, how do I move?
I think one of the options is that if you go into options
and then press gameplay and then center interact, I think it
helps with the motion sickness.
So I said gameplay center interact on?
Yeah, center interact on.
Why is it getting so steamy in here?
Oh my god.
It's like that scene in Titanic.
Yeah!
Oh, I think we're on fire!
We're on fire!
I'm not gonna help!
We haven't even started the game!
I can't even see!
I don't even know!
Go!
He.
I can't see anything either.
Oh, oh, my God!
I think I'm going.
I don't know.
I can't see.
I can't see anything.
I need to hide.
We died?
No!
This might be hell!
This might be hell, actually.
I can't see I'm just in spots Oh, we switched spots somehow
I'm all I can't see Wait, are we actually dying?
I'm gonna Get out of here Have you just had it?
Can you pat yourself?
Roll?
It's cloudy in here I can't see Why is there teeth?
What was that?
Oh my god I forgot to stay real Uh-oh.
What's going on?
Oh!
Grandma, what are you doing?
Come on.
I don't know.
I think I have dementia.
Turn the air down.
I think that's why it's foggy.
Oh, turn the air down.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I can see it again.
Vogu, are you okay?
Oh, it's cold.
The physically would just let me move.
How am I supposed to get- Why am I derogating?
Who's that dude?
Why are you- Oh, I've got it.
I got it.
Okay.
Why did- Oh, I switched these.
Awesome.
Hi, Oima.
I'm on fire.
I can't see.
I think you're still in the parking lot.
It says to go for her.
Yeah, I think you're- Can you reverse?
It says go break and that's it.
Try pressing on the back key like a You know.
Oh, I'm gonna roll down the windows.
Yeah, keep rolling them down.
You can do it for both sides.
Yeah, you guys have to do the error.
Sorry, that was me.
I had a burrito for lunch.
Are you Moku?
Yeah, I'm Moku.
I'm on your left.
Thank you.
I don't know where to look.
I'm Minto.
Whoa.
I'm on fire right now.
I'm like that dogen panel of the two garus next to the boy.
Oh, oh, I found it.
No steering wheel, no problem.
I mean, look at you reading.
I don't, I can't even see over the dashboard.
Yeah, that's the game.
That's the point.
That was the other guy's cheating you.
We all know where to go.
go top left guys oh there's a parking ticket on my booty
maybe maybe we need that to get out oh okay i can't reach it
though someone needs to get it someone needs to yeah someone
reach behind my booty grab the ticket from her booty i can't
get it what do you guys have a tape in your mouth i can't
get rid of the tape for some reason i got it i got it thank
you oh my god It's been stopped there.
I don't know why I'm trying, girl.
Why is she on fire still?
Should I?
Oh, how do I get...
Oh, okay, thank you.
Should we reset?
No, I think we got this, right?
You guys are supposed to backseat me, right?
Yeah, yeah, okay, okay, so turn the car on.
Is it not on?
The car is on.
Okay, and then...
Go to the left.
Go left.
the left oh yeah i got it got it got into the left i am i'm
pressing the i'm pressing the gas
is it oh oh it's moving it's moving oh we're moving we're
moving oh you need to wear your get me out of your cool
oh the privacy i'm trying to draw here
I think go to your right.
Go to my right.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I'm actually dead.
Go to my right.
I'm pressing.
Yeah, yeah.
Just keep going.
It's inching.
Oh.
I'm just, I'm in the cock seat now.
The what?
Is it good?
Am I good yet?
Wait, wait, wait.
You're in the where?
I'm cool.
I'm in the cock seat.
I'm cocking.
What do you mean you're in the cut seat?
You're in the front with the big, you're idiots.
Oh my god, I can't.
Oh, maybe you have to reverse and then turn right.
There's no reverse.
Oh.
Can you turn to the left then?
Can you just try?
Yeah.
Yeah, just a little bit to the left.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
We're pushing.
We're moving.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Okay, keep going.
Keep going.
Well, I...
would be ideal but yeah right right like push our way out
you know like use other cars as some kind of like a bumper
oh wait there is this reverse type of waymo what do you see
oh you found it i had to do the prindle okay i think for me
there you go there you go okay go to the right now okay go
straight oh
No, it's me!
It's me!
I'm dead!
It's dead!
Okay, okay.
There is death in this game?
Yeah.
Why am I driving?
This is not helping my Asian situation.
I'm just...
Okay.
This is not helping the stereotype.
Okay, reverse a little bit.
Oh, I can see now, I don't know.
Yeah, you're back in the...
You're back in the...
Oh, geez.
What's happening to me?
That's where I was, girl.
Enjoy the cutscene.
Oh, stop, stop, stop.
Oh, we're at a checkpoint.
Let's go.
Okay, stop.
And then go a little forward.
A little forward.
Yeah.
Just a little bit.
No.
Like this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, turn right.
Turn right.
Turn left.
Yeah, turn left.
No, no, no, no.
Keep going!
Okay!
No!
Oh, jeez.
Why are you turning the light on?
Why are you turning the light on, grandma?
It's not gonna help you see better.
I didn't turn the light on.
Can you not back on?
Oh, no, you can.
You can.
Okay, good, good, good.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Can we get Charles on our way home?
Yeah, if we can figure out how to drive the I see nothing.
I'm in the...
Do you mean...
I'm underneath the car right now.
I'm underneath the car.
Where is Mint?
Where's my wife?
She's looking in the box.
In the front.
Oh, here I am.
Oh, there I go.
There we go.
There you go.
Oh, thank you!
Okay.
Are you guys back?
Yeah, I'm back.
Oh, what's that?
There you go.
Okay, where do I go now?
The right?
Um, we're still back up a little bit?
The left or the right?
Um, go to the right.
Oh, oh, you guys wanted to go there?
Yeah, there's arrows.
Where's the arrow?
Oh, I was just saying- My bet, my bet, my bet, my bet.
Turn the reverse.
I was just saying go anywhere.
Mind, this is how you see when you draw.
I can't see shit.
What?
Whoa!
Go straight.
Why am I taking strays?
You can't be taking strays if you also in the car with me.
Wow.
I hope these people have insurance.
And then turn left Turn left.
90 degree.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, turn right.
Turn right.
Yeah, yeah, right.
Right?
Yeah, turn right.
Yeah.
I turn right.
Reverse.
Oh my god, floor it grandma floor it Wait, hold on.
Floor it.
Okay.
Floor it?
Yeah floor it right.
I want Mogu to die I want her to be in the death seat Only
two people in here are not ghosts
Wasn't it awesome?
Oh, wait, why is my scene down?
Oh, it is down.
Do I go?
Where do I go, right?
Left, left, left, left, left.
Oh, you...
Where are we?
Like this?
Oh, wrong way.
Grandma.
Wrong way?
Come on.
Okay, you back off?
I'm not even the oldest one here.
What are you talking about?
I'm insane.
We're in the same time frame.
Okay, left now, left now.
Left now.
Push.
Why are the windshield wipers on?
Oh, we're gonna hit the wall.
Floor it.
This is hard to look good.
Now back up a little, but go to your right when you back up.
Okay.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Now floor it.
Floor it straight.
straight okay turn right a little bit i
found the gas pedal i was randomly pressing it and i just
lost it this oh my god okay go right right uh-huh you gotta
reverse a little bit you gotta reverse to the left oh sorry
i was wrong
backwards okay go straight go straight floor it floor it
wait isn't those like whoa whoa oh yeah nice nice oh we need
a coin we need a coin oh I got one I got one did you guys
where do we put the coin I have one right now I can throw it
in your mouth grandma open wide i threw it to you open wide
where do i put it uh just drive forward drive straight holy
yeah drive straight floor actually if you go fast enough i
don't think we'll have to pay okay so let me back up and
then just go forward we'll pay it later yeah we can pay
later yeah yeah they're gonna mail us stuff we'll just
ignore it i can't go back can you turn the windshield wipers
off i'm getting over i don't know overstimulated back here
okay how do i so i go forward yep yep yep floor i'm flooring
it wait i'm going anywhere wait why don't we oh why am i
What?
Why am I the grandma?
Wait, what?
What's happening?
I need to go, I need a girl.
Ow!
There you go.
There's two girls now.
Oops.
What's the print?
Oh, this one?
Which one's, what's this do?
What does that do?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, that's reverse.
Okay.
What's this do?
Nothing, okay, that might be park.
Okay.
All right, I'm gonna twist it.
Oh, you need to go right.
Right, y'all.
Right.
Yeah, you have to get up a little.
Back up a little?
All right, yeah, you're literally like ramming into another
car.
That's fine, they'll cover it.
Are you guys cold?
Go straight.
Oh.
Yeah, just a little bit.
A little chilly.
Oh my God, oh my God.
I don't want to see that happening.
Oh, how do I turn the...
Oh!
Wait, why am I driving?
Oh my god!
If you click the yellow thing next to the steering wheel, it
changes person, it looks like.
Oh, the keys?
Yeah!
I'm on fire.
Yeah, why are you on fire?
Yeah, you are fire because you're so hot.
Girl, that's exactly how you use this.
Yeah, I know.
I want one trick wonder.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Wait, who's driving?
I'm driving.
Go!
Go straight!
Wait, who's this?
Who is this?
I'm in the middle.
Who are you?
Oh, you need a coin.
Can we...
Oh, here's a coin, grandma.
Grandpa.
Sorry.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sonny.
Oh, okay.
Sonny.
You're welcome.
I like how he's holding it with both of his hands.
How do I pay?
Oh, look at him.
He's so gentle with it.
How do I pay?
On the right, I think.
On the...
Do I just eat the coin out?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They'll pick it up.
Yeah, why not?
They'll understand what it means.
Okay, I did it.
Does that work?
No, I'm flooring it.
I think it's on the right.
There's like a toll thing on the right, I think.
Oh, no.
Oh.
I don't see it.
I can kind of see it.
Can you hear the skull?
Let me roll down the window.
Oh, that, and I rolled that up.
Okay.
Am I reversing?
No.
let me now yes you are oh oh now you are oh oh i see it it's
right there oh i saw it okay okay where is it oh i can do it
i can do it oh guys give a coin who has a coin i eat it i
don't have one wait i think we got rid of all the coins oh
no oh oh we up already what's this uh can we put that in
there nope can we put this tape in there uh and they don't
take tapes oh my daughter mix tape it's priceless are we
softball um oh no we already fucked up crank the heat let's
burn this place down we're taking them with us oh god yeah
alive
imagine if one of us was like oh there's a cord oh yeah i
know okay wait is there a coin no i don't see no i don't see
any can we leave the car and get it i know all right oh oh
what i haven't oh i if you press arrow keys it like gives
you direct oh i can't i but he needs a coin wait what
I can't.
Wait, you found one?
You find a coin?
Yay!
That coin is in the tree!
Wait, give it to me.
Where is it?
I have it.
Right there.
No, that's a, that's the, oh.
Oh, oh, I got it on the sea.
I got it.
Get it.
I'm stretching.
Okay.
Do I just throw it in?
Yeah, go.
Did it make it?
It's supposed to be turning the sea.
No.
It's on the sea.
It's on the right side.
at the passenger seat.
I can't reach it.
I don't see it.
Wait, wait, wait.
What's good?
I can't see it.
Oh, we're fucked.
We're sitting on the right.
It's on the right side of the passenger seat.
I was at the hardest part.
I don't know.
You see an emo kid?
No.
Yeah, I don't think you can see anything.
Come on, Grandma, you don't even know our names.
No.
You guys kind of look all the same to me.
I'm hurt.
Except one of you.
My feelings.
Not just a face, Grandma.
Wait, yeah, if you drive forward and like slam into
something, it'll jostle it.
Oh, I got it, I got it!
Okay, now back up.
We can just switch seats with Mogu and then throw it out the
window.
Yeah, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, too much, too much!
Oh, she doesn't know how to break!
Oh, she- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Um, almost there.
Dusty!
Okay, okay, wait, we're just a little?
Just a little?
We have to go back a little bit, right?
I'm playing Step Mania.
Oh, what's already playing?
Max 300.
Like this?
Am I- Oh!
Just back up a little bit?
Yeah, just back up just a tad.
Not good?
More?
More!
You're good!
Oh!
Am I good now?
Forward!
Yep.
Okay, okay.
A little more!
A little more.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Did it open?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Did it?
Floor.
Wait, did it open?
I can't see shit.
It's too cold up here.
Neither can we.
Put the windshield wipers on.
No, it's like that thing where it fogs on the inside.
me i missed wait wait wait i have another point i have
another point i have you're right okay okay don't aim so
high ah
Do I do this?
Do I risk it?
Risk it for the biscuit.
Kobe!
I missed.
Wait, did you make it?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, it's back up.
I see the coin in the car.
Yeah, yeah.
Look, they're in the front.
Yeah.
Back up, back up, back up like this.
Back up, back up.
Oh, uh, yeah.
Can you see through the flames?
Kobe.
Yeah, I think you missed again.
Can I do it?
I missed it again?
Yeah.
Well, there was like a ticket.
I don't know where that went.
I missed again.
You missed again?
How many pennies are on the floor?
Wait, do we have to put the ticket in the bird?
Oh, do we?
Where is the ticket, though?
That's so complicated.
Oh my god, where is it?
Is it this?
No, I think we're just missing the coin.
Kobe.
Uh.
We're all just...
Oh.
Oh, it went back into the car.
We're fine.
Okay, good, good.
Try again.
Kobe.
One more.
Can you drive close?
Third time's the charm.
Colby.
Yeah, I think that's the charm.
Meanto.
Did it work?
Did it go?
Wait, it didn't spawn back in the car, though.
What the heck?
Oimo.
It worked?
It's up your ass.
It's on my butt.
I can't grab it.
Okay, thank you.
Oh, go.
Wait, wait.
That's a little bath.
More a little bath.
More, back a little tiny bit.
Back a little tiny bit.
And you reverse a little bit.
And to the right.
Like that?
More?
Wait, we're going forward somehow?
How are we going?
Oh, I'm not.
I'm backing up.
Oh, like this.
Um.
Mogu.
Uh.
Wait, did that work?
No.
Did it?
I can't see, remember?
Uh, like, the...
Did it work, guys?
No.
The coin disappeared.
Oh.
uh there's no coin anymore oh i see it i see a coin here you
go oh where did oh there it is thank you desko oh man i
think i see the coin it's under the seat me too did it work
oh my god wait can you reverse it a little bit maybe A
little bit.
Yeah, reversal if it's close to the plate.
I think we're too far, maybe.
It doesn't look like it's going that far.
I feel like something must be missing.
Oh, oh, nice, nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
And go forward.
Okay, nice, nice.
Go forward to the right a little.
Yeah.
The windows roll down, right?
Down, it's down.
Yeah, it's down.
Like that?
Like this?
Oh, that's pretty good, this one.
Is that good?
I can't get the coin.
Oh, it's by you.
It's by you.
Yeah.
It's by me?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's two.
Oh, yeah, here.
Oh, you don't want to do it?
You could be the gamer.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, wait.
Reverse a little bit.
Toby.
Got it?
No.
I have a coin.
Let me try.
Yeah, there's more coins.
Oh, okay.
Switch, switch.
I'll switch.
Yep.
And go forward.
right yeah just a little bit how do i switch with you see oh
there we go okay yeah it's too far i think okay i got this
you got this you got this i used to be a basketball manager
manager right yeah i used to because i like slum dunk so
much oh i'm gonna say you read kuroko no basket and that's
when you said you're a manager i did read kuroko on the
basket too okay how you just determined it are you good no
i'm good A little bit.
I think this is too far.
No!
Oh my god!
Dude, I'm like the worst driver in this car, I think.
I don't think...
Oh!
Close, close.
So close.
Okay, okay.
And...
Oh, is that good?
Uh...
Forward!
Oh, you need to go straight, you know how to do that.
I went straight in my entire life.
Have your coin ready!
That's it.
What are you guys doing?
Okay, how do I do this?
Okay, how do I switch with you?
I don't even know which paddle is which paddle.
Oh, oh.
Did you shoot it?
Oh.
Is it glitch?
Is it bugged?
because it's like it's like stopping I think we're just bad
I can try switching Switch You wanna try switching Arm Do
you want Um Okay wait wait wait wait Wait let me try driving
Yeah yeah How do I switch Press the yellow thing Press the
yellow car key Yeah yeah yeah yeah Oh okay okay yeah Alright
I'm in the car Okay kids where you want to go
out of here are we reversing or how is this uh we're facing
right at the coin thingy yeah the coin machine why won't it
reverse You have to switch the Prindle.
Oh, this is...
No, this is forward.
Okay.
What's a Prindle?
That's what it's called.
P-R-D-L.
P-R-O-O-O.
P-R-N-D-L.
Wait, hold up.
It's closer to Dusty.
Where are we?
I'll be facing backwards though, no?
I don't think I can make that.
that hold on kids oh dad kids hold on grandma please i'm
turning our hazards on oh nice oh oh how do i get how do you
go okay this way it's harder to look right this way and then
floor it floor it oh okay ran to a wall yeah yeah yeah it's
okay it's okay we got this we got this got this reverse it's
the five-point turn we're like sandwiched in between cars oh
no yeah you're you're sandwiched between like literally a
car and a wall yeah oh gosh okay you had to do that thing we
had to move forward then back up then move the forward then
back okay we might be going backwards but it's just believe
oh hold on oh you made a u-turn oh my god okay we're fine
get back there get Okay.
Yeah, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
I know how to do this.
Yeah, you gotta...
Okay.
Looking good, looking good.
Okay, alright.
Wait, you're kind of gaming.
I know how to drive, that's why.
I know how to drive, that's why!
Oh my god, let's go!
Oh my god!
Oh shoot, wait, wait, wait.
Dude, if we ever were doing a road trip together, we're all
fucked.
We were so fucked.
Like, okay, okay, back up to a little bit.
Yeah, awful, be like, why do you put somebody dumb ass
bitches in the same car?
Okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, Oh, that's pretty good,
that's pretty good.
Okay, okay, okay.
Forward a little.
Just a little bit.
Okay.
Forward little.
The steering wheel, like, totally...
It spins.
It does, it does spin.
It's so fucking awful.
Go again, go again, go again.
Is that good or no?
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
It's like two to three hours long.
We're literally going to be here for two to three hours.
Ah, this is the final boss.
This is the first boss.
Wait.
The window is down?
No, no, you just put it up.
No.
That's what I'm saying.
It like when you throw it, it acts like it hits against the
window.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
I got it.
You got it?
I believe it.
I believe in you Straight Alright grandma Straight Straight
Like just straight Straight to the right Okay Oh you're good
You're good A little bit to your right Just a little bit
Just a slight right Yeah You're doing it You're good You're
good No yeah Okay Kobe No Okay Don't You just Hey kids I'm
trying Grandma's trying
Wait, this way.
Oh, remember to bring some change if you choose Neil for
your next set of wheels.
We will lock you in the slot if you try to leave without
paying except in the invoice.
How do you pay?
Wait, can we just leave?
Yeah, can we leave?
I don't know.
I'm okay with committing crimes.
I'm old.
I'll never, they'll never.
Yeah, they'll never catch me.
I'll be done before I finish.
Am I close?
Left a little?
No, you're nowhere close.
Who said right?
Oh, oh, stop!
Oh, stop!
Oh, what?
Oh, back up just a little bit.
Oh, my God, so close.
It's just a little bit.
Like that.
Just a little bit.
You're good.
Keep going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, oh, stop!
Hold up, hold up.
Oh!
Oh my God!
Ah!
Did you do it?
Feel it good?
Fly!
Oh, I'm reversing.
Wait, hold on!
We did that one!
We told we did that!
Yeah!
Free!
I'm free!
Oh my god!
Oh, who's that?
She ran into another car and your grandson is...
I think his neck is broken.
Who are you?
Oh, I am going berserk.
Oh, I guess you got a kid.
Oh, I'm not.
We're good.
Does anyone want to be the driver now?
Okay, I could try.
Okay.
That's me.
Oh.
Let's go, I'm up.
No, it's me.
I don't know how to get out of here, actually.
Are there arrows?
Wait.
Is left go forward or right go forward?
Right, right, right.
It's like you said you knew how to drive.
Wait, Oimo, she doesn't know how to drive.
Left is brake.
Yeah, left is brake.
Oh, left is brake.
Go fast.
And I reverse using this?
Yep.
The Prindle.
Yes.
The Prindle?
The middle is back?
No.
This is back?
Oimo, you never drove in a car before in your life.
Okay, we're going way back.
We're going back into the garage.
Hold up.
Okay, forward?
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
I think we're running over people.
That's fine.
Yeah, what are we running over?
Why are you so bumpy?
Whoa!
Oh!
Right, right, right, right.
Hard, right!
I got...
I got funked out of my feet.
Oh, yeah, you did.
Okay.
Right, right, right, right, right, right, right.
Go, go!
That's straight.
Can you...
Oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
Come on, grandpa.
Ah, crap.
But once in your life, don't go straight.
Oh, grandpa, great.
Okay.
Like crank that wheel.
Oh, that's close.
That's close.
You just kind of ran over a car.
Drift!
Oh.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Hold that working guy.
Yeah, you're gaming.
Just go backwards.
Keep going backwards.
That's not backwards.
We're back to where we love these cars.
Right, right, right, right, right.
Hard right, right, right.
Hard right!
Where are we?
Back up and then go right.
Yeah, you're good?
You're good?
Right.
Oh, you turned on the light.
You okay?
Hey, who died?
Hey, who are you?
Hey, come back.
Okay.
And then...
Go right.
Right!
Right.
Yeah, you're fine.
You got it.
Which way are we supposed to go?
Okay.
To the right.
There's that.
Oh, wait, but there's arrows pointing left.
Hmm.
Maybe that's for the other side when we get out of this
door.
I think you're right.
Where are we even trying to go?
Oh, no, yeah.
It says right.
Come on in.
Drive through the doors.
Drive through the door.
Where?
Okay.
Right, right, right, right, right.
Oh!
Grandpa, stop!
Grandpa, you're setting me up!
Oh no!
Again, I...
I know that's meant.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
This is so stressful.
It does say come on in.
I think you just go inside.
Yeah, we just go inside.
Meals, peals.
Do anything.
Peals on wheels.
Go inside and pregnant the store.
Okay, I'm gonna go right.
Yeah.
Give them another car baby.
Left?
Yeah, car baby.
What?
Is that like a- It's like a- It's like a- Oh, you gotta- You
gotta back up.
Sweetie.
Sweetie, you gotta back up.
We hurt, we hurt honey.
Honey, please reverse.
Yeah, please.
Am I not backing up?
No.
No, you're not.
Yeah, the lever needs to be back, I think.
The Prindle.
The Prindle's gotta be back.
The Jork.
Yeah.
I'm gonna hide people.
people okay are we out of gas that's a thing no is that a
thing i don't think so i think this is an electric car is no
okay i don't think this is an electric car a cyber truck
it's a cyber am i reversing you're no you're not no you're
not are you press we haven't moved no no yeah it's we're
pretty stuck i'm passing it no okay okay you want someone
else try driving okay okay okay no no everything looks right
hey oh wait why we reversed so hard i ice cubed no way
grandma grandma please i'm frozen Oh my god, are you cold?
I'm- I'm- oh!
Oh!
Oh god, oh god, it's all going to shit!
It's all going to shit!
Get Oibo out of the car- out of the sea!
Oh, sevens!
Wait, are we not going forward?
No!
I think you're holding on to me.
You're like, you're throwing me right- oh hi.
Oh my god.
Mom, mom, mom.
forward i don't know where we're going i can't see it's cold
in this car grandma turn on the heat grandma put me back in
the back seat she's just gonna get colder oh hell yeah okay
the best way to melt the ice is with fire uh your grand one
of your grandkids are you're stepping on your grandkids
right now oh geez oh oh i love Oh my god
Guys the pedal came off.
It's hell.
It's my bag.
I'm slipping out of the car grandma, please I'm out of the
door I'm clipping out of the door I'm clipping out of the
door I'm clipping out of the door Oh, I swear I don't What
is happening?
Oh, are we not going right away?
Oh, I don't know I already seeing fire oh you're so close
you got to go to the right you got to go to the right you
did it okay now back up and go to the right to the right
more the right the now now go to the right yeah go to the
right floor it why do you floor it everywhere you have to
commit you have to commit go go go go okay wait maybe the
magazines are in our way okay yeah it's it's back up a
little bit and then it's kind of hard to see with all the
fire why are you still burning sorry here oh i think we're
going back to where we're at okay go right Oh, yeah, yeah,
go, go, go, go, straight, straight, straight.
Get to the left, to the left.
Yeah, to the left, to the left.
Oh, oh, yeah.
No, no, no, no.
Wait, hold up.
Okay, where are we?
All right, turn to the left.
Wait, we're so close.
Oh, oh, oh, you just turned all the way around.
Okay, reverse, reverse straight.
Yeah, just back up, just back up, just back up.
You're good, you're good.
Oh, okay.
You guys good?
Oh, my God.
You guys okay back?
I heard.
an alarm i think my neck is broken grandpa are we criminals
now oh no we're good we're good we're good okay okay okay
where am i going um uh left back up a little back up a
little back up a little yeah back up to your right go turn
to your right uh turn to my right turn the wheel to the
right and back up oh oh oh i think you're good yeah now you
can oh oh wait we're at the front desk now how the hell we
can either go inside or we can follow the arrows that are on
the right of us and then i don't know oh oh oh god who are
you buddy who are you grandpa grandpa is this old man yaoi
yes Get back in there!
Okay, both of them need to be old manually.
Well, I'm old in spirit.
Oh, oh, oh, how did you almost pull up the car?
Where are we?
Um...
Wait, what happened to...
Oh, wait, showroom is behind us.
Um, Mogu?
Um...
It's right behind us.
Um, Mogu?
Um...
Mogu?
i think this is a great chance to say that i'm actually
fluent in chinese and and um i can't be judged by my driving
skills as a person i think whoa whoa whoa i think three of
us are asian and i'm i'm gonna just i'm i'm gonna just for
it i can't for it back off oh no you guys you guys need me
okay We need you, OEMO, we need you!
I need you, OEMOE!
YOPEN!
Oh no, I was mega- I think we might be mega stuck.
Oh, sorry.
No, just shake the car!
Just shake the car?
Yeah, shake the car!
Okay, whatever!
Shake the car!
Shake, shake, shake!
Shake, shake, shake, shake, shake!
Shake it!
Shake the car!
Oh, wait, I was gonna...
I think we're actually stuck.
no way no way put me in i'll get us out i'll get us out okay
okay okay put me in put me in okay oh god i'm kind of scared
now use cold boomers for 10 off gamer stuff let's go boomer
back in my day um horses are we where are we i can't tell
where we are uh we're sideways something.
The showroom is almost...
Oh my god!
I have to utilize every power!
Ah!
I'm like, hold up, hold up.
I think roasted alive!
Wait, wait.
I smell delicious!
Are we okay?
Everyone good?
No, it's hot.
Yeah, we're good.
I'm okay.
It's a little tight in here, but I'll do.
Yeah, yeah.
Guys, I think we're stuck.
I was like, oh.
Do you try moving forward?
Yeah, I tried.
Do you try moving back?
How do we even get here?
I don't know how we got here.
What did you do, Mogu!
Oh, yeah.
Do we win the game?
You can reset the checkpoint.
Oh, let's try reset the checkpoint.
How do you do that?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Where are we?
We're upside down?
We're literally in heaven.
I found a coin.
Hold up, hold up.
If this is heaven, I don't want to leave.
I can't see anything out the windows.
Here.
Can I have the hand?
Oh, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Here, I'll roll the window down for you.
Oh, we're up right, we're up right now.
We're up right!
Where are we though?
I can't see anything.
Where do we go?
Everybody, please look outside.
yeah windows are foggy there's some silent back up and then
go slightly right yeah I'm defrosting I'm defrosting oh
you're defrosting okay oh nice oh nice okay where are we oh
I can I can tell I can tell I think we gotta go left right
no I think so wait how do I wait are you saying that we
should go left or right wait this way left left top left oh
stop shop shop okay we're literally in front of the showroom
yeah i'm going to i crashed into it but nothing happened we
gotta go in we gotta go in go in i need a new car it's
almost black friday
my bad everyone good yeah yeah yeah i think we're fine we're
fine we're fine we're fine are we supposed to go in the
front desk Sorry.
Oh, I think so.
Yeah, I think so.
Looks like it.
Right?
The right, yeah.
Oh no, right now you're hitting like a white band.
Yeah, they're fine.
They won't they won't they won't know It'll fall foul.
Yeah, I'm gonna leave.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're gonna be fine.
I'm gonna leave the oil in formation there So they can
contact.
Oh good good good good good.
Excuse me.
Yeah, yeah.
I will have oil take care of it Wait, I don't know.
That's the point How embarrassing.
I think you do have to crash into it.
Okay.
Floor it, grandma.
Floor it.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Wait, where am I?
Sonny, help.
Oh.
I'll be it.
Look at my child.
Oh, wait.
I will leave.
Why are you here?
Where do you go?
You're like me too.
Wait, I don't know how to get you back.
them you can throw them to the back oh no i can't i don't
know i can't reach all right wait who was that oh oh you're
back you're back you're fine i'm back i'm fine i'll oh what
happened where'd you go uh i went to the underside of the
car uh we changed our oil so that's pretty good um i don't
know where we are should i just follow the arrow that i see
that says go right yeah so if i go i don't think you can go
that way no i can't see what crap what crap oh it's blocked
off oh it's blocked okay okay you reverse in to the showroom
you might be able to show yeah trying like a hard left hard
left reverse reverse left um um okay hold on i'm gonna floor
it forward
Floor backward.
Okay.
Okay, everyone's fine.
Floor it backward.
Okay, we're good.
Okay, back.
Yeah, floor.
Just come on in.
Oh.
No?
We're still being stuck on the door, I think.
Yeah, the walls or something.
Dude, I don't think we fit.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is perfect.
This is the optimal angle.
Oh, whoops.
Wait.
Oh, oh, wait.
It's not so optimal anymore.
Will it?
Wait, which way should I go?
Floor?
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Wait, are we making it?
Are we?
Are we going in?
I can go forward a little more.
Let's go.
We're like right in front of the car.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Should I go backwards?
Imagine that you're reversing into a parking spot that's on
your left.
Wait, what?
Just reverse, but like imagine the parking spot is on your
left.
We're reversing in.
Do you know how to reverse park?
It's mint, right?
Yeah, she knows.
We're in.
Oh, let's go!
Yes, Sunny!
Okay, go left.
I'm trying.
Oh, wait.
I think I'm reversing.
I was reversing.
That's my bad.
My bad.
Here, let me reverse a little bit more.
You kids.
Oh, wait, wrong way.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, am I about to leave?
Yeah, you're about to leave.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Wait, what do I do?
Can I...
Oh, go right.
Uh, go...
Why go right?
I mean, I mean, I mean, go left.
Go left, go left, go left.
Straight?
Wait.
Left, but don't go straight.
If you go straight, you'll...
Oh, back up, back up again, and then put your steering wheel
to the right.
Turn...
I'm beaming some people.
That's okay.
But my steering wheel to the right.
Wait, to the right?
find them for life uh like that oh yeah yeah yeah we're back
in i think how die in and then we need to go left yeah oh i
messed it up no no you didn't mess it up classic grandma
yeah classic grandma oh grandma oh you your eyes are just
not what it used to be oh oh oh if you're cooking You're
cooking?
You're cooking?
I'm cooking?
You're cooking!
Let's go!
Hold on!
Stop!
Go forward.
Now left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Get out of here.
I need someone to kiss my lips.
Who's turning the air down?
What'd you do that for?
Oh, grandma has bad bones.
I can't have it cold.
It's too cold in here.
Alright, alright, alright.
Oh.
Thank you, Grandma.
Thank you.
Nice and toasty.
Alright, where do I go?
I mean, what smells delicious?
Left?
Yeah.
Oh wait.
Uh, you...
Wrong way.
Dude, these controls are so hard.
The wrong way?
The wrong way.
We're about to leave the dealership again.
Again?
Wait, if I go straight, will we leave?
Yeah, if you go straight, we will leave.
Oh, God.
Oh, my bad.
I think you think I'm still on fire.
Hold on.
I'll get us back inside.
Perfect.
Okay, okay, okay.
Are we inside?
Now go left.
Okay.
Go left.
Go left forward left.
little bit forward and a lot of left.
Yeah, just a little bit.
Yeah, you're doing it.
You're doing it.
Oh, you're doing it.
Oh, wait, gaming.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, I'm looking at you.
More left, more left.
And then...
Wait, do I...
Can you smash the window?
Oh, I think I smash the window again.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let me back up.
Okay, gosh, this is like testing my driving ability to
actually the max.
say now nobody could say nobody could have a bad driver
anymore right chat it's pretty good i think i'm actually the
worst one ah i don't think that would be the car we're fine
right who's on fire okay go left go along your side go your
other left your other my other left my bed we're fine like
this way oh
Oh, we're in a corner.
Oh, it's too high.
We're also on fire.
Night of fire.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Night of fire.
I'm melting.
My children.
My children are on fire.
Hold on.
I'll make it a little cold.
Yeah?
Could I have it a little cold?
Thank you.
We're fine.
Everything's good, right, everybody?
Thank you.
You love hanging out with grandma!
Yay!
Grandma!
When's the last time you got your license plate?
What?
When's the last time you got your driver's license?
Back in!
So it was 1775.
God damn.
Columbus sailed the ocean blue.
You were bored.
Where am I?
Okay.
You were telling us how you got your driver's license.
Yeah?
Yes I was?
Oh, wait.
Whoa!
What is that?
Okay.
A filing cabinet.
Oh yeah, yeah.
What do I do?
Where do- Oh.
It's that way.
Go back up and then left.
Okay, good, good, good.
Oh, good, good.
And then like all the way left.
Go all the way left?
Yeah we got hard left.
Yeah hard left everybody.
Hold on to your seatbelt.
Browse.
Oh my god.
Oh wait wait okay okay.
Back and do the same thing.
Okay okay.
I think so.
Wait I always have to remember which way.
I do this.
Wait no.
Yeah.
Oh yeah!
Okay.
And then...
And then floor it.
Floor it!
You're speaking my love language.
Let's go!
You're doing great, Grandma.
We are in first place.
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
I think you're gonna...
Oh!
Hold on, I'll take care of you in a second, Sunny.
Let's see the light.
I'm fading.
I don't care.
okay you're going great you're doing great now let's move it
straight straight straight just straight like floor it oh oh
my god is everybody okay yes yes yes yeah yeah how do we how
do we we're not in our toll oh we're toll booth oh oh
where's our ticket uh we need to have a ticket coin oh i
found a coin okay i'm done driving everybody good luck
somebody else okay like somebody else you guys got a coin oh
i don't see oh there i see oh it says it has to be a ticket
oh the ticket oh my gosh wait we saw the ticket but it's
been gone ever since oh i i see the ticket i see the ticket
where are you guys oh yeah i got it i got it i got it oh you
got it okay back up okay okay okay okay back up a little bit
tiny bit are you good where is oh keep going keep going just
a little bit more keep going a little bit more stop stop
yeah you need to go forward grandpa
i love how they like don't even oh wait we're going back
inside we're going back inside
The park.
This is my life ends.
Hey, go to the right a little bit maybe.
Oh yeah, we're gonna hit a wall.
No, go right.
Go right.
Someone's outside the car.
That's me.
Okay, you can put me back out.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, are you guys all back in?
Right, right, right, right, right.
Right, right.
Prindal off.
Push a Prindal.
Oh, you have to put it back on.
You have to put it on yourself, Grandpa.
Come on.
You have an engineering degree, don't you?
Was engineering even, like, developed when you were like?
Girls in STEM.
Okay.
We love girls in STEM.
All right.
Hard right.
Hard as hard as you can go.
You just have to go right.
Oh, okay, good, good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
too hard too hard okay now to the left to the left okay okay
take it back now y'all steer left this time just go straight
okay okay okay okay slowly not slowly forward fast forward
right right go right
one hour it took us one hour Oh my god!
It took us an hour.
We got it.
Only 22 bumps.
I don't believe that.
What is that?
A cane?
Yeah.
A new spindle?
That's a sick spindle.
Look at that.
It's the prindle.
Prindle.
I can't believe we did it.
We never park anymore.
We just go straight.
The spindle.
His floor.
He's got to go fast.
The mint carried hard.
I know.
No, no.
Mindy was like the best driver.
I never expected that.
I'm pretty good at driving.
I've never had a ticket or an accident.
Oh my God, save him.
I'm pretty good.
I took my riding exam eight times before I passed.
Oh, well, the first time I took my driving exam, I drove on
the wrong side of the road.
Yay.
So maybe I am pretty good at this game.
Yeah.
Okay, I guess we go next.
Yeah, let's go.
What?
What is this Simlish going on?
Wasn't it in English?
Yeah, I think it was.
It was originally right.
What's happening?
What's the topic is that?
Sorry guys, I had a Chipotle for lunch.
Oh, whoa.
Where are we going?
Traffic time!
Oh, we do have a new spindle.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Oh.
Spindle.
Oh, there's a tape in your mouth.
Oh, here.
What's this thing?
Okay, where am I going?
Where are we going?
Let's just go straight for now, I guess.
Yeah, floor.
Yay!
Oh, wait, actually, that worked!
Wait, this is working!
Just keep going!
Wait, just keep going!
Hold up, what?
Oh, grandma, it was a red light.
Oh, go, go, go, go,
go!
It wasn't green.
That guy is...
No, no, no, go straight.
Go straight, go straight.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Are we at the light?
Um, hold on, hold on.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Yeah!
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Oh, I think you hit a person.
No, that's a tree.
um oh oh why are trees in the middle of the road anyway huh
oh grandma your teeth grandma your teeth oh my dentures yeah
take them back i don't want to touch them nasty grandma can
we go to the gun stores right there oh yeah we're gonna get
hit by traffic okay i got to the divorce lounge the revolver
oh my god okay okay go go go go go go go go go go Who's
that?
Hold up, hold up, hold up.
Don't worry about it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, I think we're on a pole.
That's why we're on a pole.
It wants me to revert.
It wants me to click on this.
Okay.
I think someone else has to try.
Oh, what?
Wait, what?
It wouldn't let me do anything.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, okay.
Good.
Okay, good.
Go to the right a little, maybe.
Yeah, go to the right a little.
Oh, okay.
We're on another pole.
reverse a little bit there's a psychiatric clinic for big
thinkers whose stomach was that oh my god bacon all right go
to the left and floret like this what's a floret oh my god
hi oh grandma oh grandma
back up back up yeah i'm backing up wait which way did we
come from uh from the left we want to go to the right yeah
we kind of want to go to the right okay is that blood on
mine on the windshield or mm-hmm I'm going I'm going oh oh
oh go go go go go go oh no no Wait, um, we're gonna get
Wait, wait
Alright, now Floor it Floor it We were so close Oh, are we
really?
That's gonna be fun after this I dropped my phone
We're playing like the most intense frog Or ever Oh, wait If
you do, I should wait one now.
And...
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
Wait, how?
How?
That one's tough.
Okay.
Go, go, go!
Go, go!
Yeah, I think you have to be, like, really preemptive.
Like, like, start going a little bit and then...
Oh, well, um, a little...
A little.
I'm gonna pee myself.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go.
Go a little bit.
Go like a tiny bit.
Go, go, go.
I can't just let me go.
What's happening?
Oh, no.
Maybe we need to switch again.
I think, I think Agarwal is...
Oh, no, I'm missing the pedals on the car.
I'm missing the...
I'm missing the pedals for the car.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
You see it?
Uh-oh.
I don't see it.
Oh, there's one.
Oh, oh, I just saw.
Oh, I found a pedal off now.
There you go, there you go.
Where?
That's a tape.
I hear it to you.
Why is the music so silly?
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Yeah, yeah, I was right over there.
Okay, okay, ready?
When can I go?
Right after this?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Wait, you can't even see the traffic?
Who farted?
No, ew.
Who did that?
Ew, why is it stinky?
Oh, they have.
Roll the window down!
What's wrong with someone's stomach?
Mogu is that you?
Mogu!
Stop eating Chipotle, you know what it does to you.
You're not about to share a room with you.
No!
Go?
I can't help it!
Yeah!
We're going!
I think we need to go to the left or right maybe?
Are we gonna try it on the sidewalk?
I think we need to go to the left.
The left, yeah.
The right is on block.
Yeah.
Oh, back up?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, there you go, Moku.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Back up!
Back it up!
I'm back in the...
I think I'm stuck.
Oh, no.
Wait, no, you're not.
Don't say that.
Oh, God.
Who, who, who, who?
Uh.
I'm going to roll the windows up before y'all dies.
That's just how it is.
I don't know where we are.
I don't know.
Who's- who's yelling?
Who's saying expletives?
Someone have poop?
I- uh...
Uh, I think I fucked.
Huh?
Oh, maybe you have to drive on top of the cars?
I don't think so.
There's- No, I think you go- Go to the left.
Okay, we have to back up.
Yeah, we gotta back up.
Back up?
Okay.
Can we back up?
Is this a front wheel or a back wheel drive?
Um...
It's a no-wheel drive.
Okay.
What's that supposed to mean?
Okay, I'm gonna gas it.
Don't gas it, please.
Okay.
It's already pretty stinky in here.
I think we might have to restart.
How do you restart?
Yeah, the set point.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, but you have to go forward again, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
If I can do it, you can do it.
I'm scratching my head.
It's an overkill.
Okay.
Yeah!
Yeah, now stop, stop, stop, stop!
Oh.
Oh, ew!
You're like my cat.
Scared the poop out of you.
Alright, now go to your left.
Back up.
Go to my left?
Okay.
Yeah.
Why am I stuck?
Oh, I lost the pedal.
Oh, no!
I don't see it.
I probably need to cuddle.
Grandpa!
Oh wait, wait, I think I saw it.
Is that it?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
You saw it?
Oh, you got it?
Okay, good.
It's cold.
What am I doing?
Turn to the left, hard left.
No, we're trying to go to the left.
Oh, hit the guy.
Hit the guy, yeah.
Don't forget what happened.
What guy?
Hard left.
Just go forward.
Am I going forward?
Hard left?
No, I think it's left.
No.
There you go.
Go straight, go straight, go straight.
Wait!
Oh, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, we hit a checkpoint though.
That's good.
Now to the right.
Also, don't forget me.
Oh, okay, never mind.
Oh, I'm like, wait, what happened to us?
Where are you?
Wait, I'm in here.
I'm in the middle seat.
Wait, did I lose Mint?
Yeah, I'm out of the car.
Okay.
No, no, no.
Okay, go on right a little bit.
The Prindal.
Oh, yeah, we're the Prindal.
Where's my Prindal?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
It's not that.
It's in the front.
I'm throwing this cash out.
I'm trying to reach it.
There you go.
Ugh.
Oh, thank you.
You just threw it up.
Where am I supposed to go?
Sorry.
Right?
A little bit?
Like 90 degrees.
Forward?
Right?
That way.
90 degrees, yeah.
Forward, right.
90 degrees.
Oh, yeah, good, good, good.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Uh.
Reverse.
Okay.
And then left reverse.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're doing it?
Grandpa's an iPad kid!
Yeah.
There you go.
What's our iPad?
What's your cocoa melon?
I don't want cocoa melon.
Do they have cocoa melon for grandpaws and grand- for
grandparents?
I think this is what- Oh wait, Sean, sorry.
Wrong way.
You gotta go back a little.
You're hitting a- Back?
Yeah, you're hitting a fire hydrant.
Your mama's a fire hydrant.
Wait, aren't we supposed to turn around though?
Are we turning around?
around no i think this is the way right yeah we got it oh
there you go there you go there you go yeah now go straight
now go straight go straight or turn to your left and go
straight like that yeah yeah yeah good good good really good
oh wait hold up it's we got another checkpoint so i think
we're going the right way oh you're supposed to go into the
park into the park yeah back up
Oh my gosh, I'm in your lap.
Oh my god.
Mwah.
Get back to you.
I looked at you.
Again.
How am I supposed to make it?
Get back.
Oh.
No, no.
You're about to back into the park.
So you're doing pretty good.
Okay.
So do I back into the park or do I U-turn or like- Yeah, you
could probably back in.
Back it in.
For it.
Pack that ass up.
If I back it up, is it fat enough?
No, you're moving a little though.
You might be able to.
Yeah, you might be able to.
Oh.
We're squeezing in.
Parallel parking, damn.
Oh, we're, like, going the wrong way.
Oh, no, never mind.
Whoa, actually.
Okay, and then I could go straight, right?
Turn it the other way.
Ah, no.
And then turn back, backwards.
Wait, there's money.
Oh, there's money.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm breaking.
Where are you going?
Break it.
That's not the break.
Now, screw it.
Oh, wait.
I see the light.
I think that's just a car light, honey.
Oh, okay.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, someone's gonna poop if they, if you hit too hard.
I always hit hard.
A little bit back in there.
I, to the right and floor.
more to the right like this oh to the left oh oh so close
right right right this is still good right wait yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're going back oh yeah we're going in reverse
we're going to reverse reverse very little very little okay
nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice i can't reverse
anymore on the gate we're on the gate okay okay okay you're
so close okay we're So close.
We're like, so close.
That's just on the right, like, 90%.
I'm going.
And I'm back.
I'm trying.
Oh, am I doing it?
Oh, no.
You're doing good.
Are we in?
Like a shark right here.
We're in.
We're like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah, we're in the park.
Wait.
Grandma the money, the grandma, the money.
Where's the money?
Grandma, we need money.
We're poor.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Who's this?
That's me.
Hi.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Okay, go.
back to your seat like to your seat i feel like you're the
grandma from sponge bob
okay where i go i don't know yeah we already hit the statue
i think oh did we let's go that statue is right there and
there's like something in front of it oh yeah there was like
something glowing oh whatever oh oh oh nice you can oh oh my
gosh oh suddenly it feels like Sorry.
I can't see anything.
Am I there yet?
Grandma, please.
You're sitting on my corpse.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Mwah.
There you go.
No, I'm so good.
You're still...
Oh, wait.
It's okay.
Don't tell mom, don't tell mom.
Oh, see those X's on the gate?
Wait, there's the X's on the gate.
It might be that we hit those, maybe?
Where?
Left or right?
Straight.
Oh, wait, wait.
No, you're right.
You're right.
You're racial.
Floor it straight.
Floor it.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, nearly.
Oh, no.
Oh, gosh.
Everyone's dead.
Everyone is dead.
I'm behind you, Oimo.
I know.
Sits on you.
Sits off.
Oh, you guys are both dead.
Whoa.
Like this?
Where am I going?
It worked.
This way?
um to the right oh geez so close um okay when you're oh wait
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh wait wait are we right behind it no
no no it's your uh yeah like this yeah and then and then
what back it up yes yeah yeah oh my gosh wait ah so close
okay it's two year left now Oh, no.
No, no.
Okay, back it up.
Oh, there's a tree.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Go to your right quite a bit and then floor it.
What the heck?
Like this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good angle.
Great angle.
Okay, where am I?
Back it up a tiny bit.
Reverse a little.
Yeah, yeah.
Like a little bit.
And now go.
Oh, good girl.
Oh, this is good.
This is good.
Yeah, to your right.
Yeah, a little bit.
Can I ride a little bit?
Forward right?
Yeah, forward right.
Oh, my tummy.
Like this?
Okay, now floor it straight!
Forward straight!
Floor it!
Wait!
Did I not make it?
No, you did that not what we're supposed to do?
Is there the other exit that's over there on the right?
I'm missing a pedal.
Yay!
What pedal are you missing?
I got it.
Am I there yet?
Am I doing good?
Do we need more gas, gas, gas?
He's- what if you guys are shooting?
I'm sorry!
I'm trying to think!
Whoa, something's going on in here.
Oh, your seat's down, I think.
There you go.
There you go, buddy.
That's not another gate.
Where am I supposed to go?
Wait, I don't know.
Yeah, I think go straight.
Oh, where am I?
Am I going straight?
Oh.
Yeah, go straight.
Go straight and a right.
Oh, straight and a right.
Little bit to your right.
Oh, I keep pressing the right.
Oh, I did my left, sorry.
No, that's okay.
Wait, don't say that.
It's not okay.
Oh, you're a great.
You're doing great, sweetie.
I'm going to floor it.
Hold on.
Floor it.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, there's, I see that you guys, I see the exit of this
if I can't like...
Yeah, it's weird.
Is it on, like, where the building is on, like, behind us?
Is that what it was supposed to be?
Yeah.
I feel like this pamphlet is supposed to help us.
Is it?
What does it say?
Yeah, read it.
Oh, sorry.
I'm just...
There you go.
It just says, like, don't miss the park statue, which is
where we were just at.
It says local low down.
The model pipe and loop back beneath the statue, etc.
etc.
What?
Huh?
Yeah, they give you information.
Wait, so we need to go to the statue then?
Okay.
Over here.
There's something underneath the statue yeah, there was like
something glowing.
Yeah, okay, is that why we're locked in because we will have
to loot We have to loot the statue Let's get to looting.
Okay.
There's the statue right in front of it.
No way.
Okay pour it girl Pour it.
Oh, no, no.
No, no, no.
I see it.
Oh, back up back up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah We're backing it up.
We're backing it up That ass up back that dumpy up mint
Okay, now move a little bit to your left and then forward
okay okay good good good good yeah okay now make keep going
a little bit to your left and forward just keep going little
by little oh good good good good good keep going more left
or forward just forward just a little bit yeah i think the
statue is like literally right in front of us oh wait i
think i see oh wait do we see the the glowing thing yeah i
think back up just a little bit just like a tiny bit just
like oh yeah gold pipe and bag what do we just take it yeah
take it take it grab it oh what's going on i can't grab i
can't grab it you can grab it's a button oh there's a button
on the bag of money oh get the money get the money yeah
press forward a little bit forward a little bit like point
point okay yeah yeah yeah perfect perfect no one press it
can't seem to press it okay you try i can't reach do we have
to like grab it from the there's no way we can grab that
right guys i thought this was a driving game not a puzzle
game did you grab wait wait wait wait i i get it did you get
it um um we're gonna here's a pedal uh we're gonna i'm gonna
eat okay eat what's the glowing thing on the corner of the
park too.
What is happening?
God, my grandson looks so stupid.
I'm sorry.
I got it from you.
My beautiful daughter should have never married that ugly
guy.
Oh my god, damn.
Why can't I roll the windows down?
Is there blood on the windows?
Yeah, there's blood on the windows.
Is it really nice?
Um, you can't roll it down?
I can roll it down.
Okay.
But how do we, uh...
It says it's missing the bag of money.
How are we supposed to get the bag?
I think it's supposed to drop.
Wait, there's something golden in front of us.
Do you guys see on the left?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see.
Grandma, go straight and a little bit to the left.
Straight.
And we put it on top.
And a little bit to the left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you see it's missing the loot right now?
Am I still left?
Still left?
Uh, it's still a little bit left.
Yeah, like this.
Please stop throwing paint.
Do I see that there's a loop back there that's glowing?
Still left?
I can't see.
Oh, I see it.
I see it a little bit left and forward.
It's on top of the trash can.
It's like literally top left.
Oh yeah, you're so good.
Oh yeah, I see something.
Move a little bit to your left, grandma.
Oh, uh-uh.
I can't go in there.
over the tree we ran over a lot of trees let's say wait no i
think you have to back up a little bit and then you might
have to back up a little bit like yeah yeah and then go
forward oh go a little bit right yeah to the right okay just
a little bit oh it's so close it's so close it's so close
bro why don't you why don't we just get out of the car yeah
i know i was literally gonna say that i was literally gonna
say can you get it can you get it no it's no it's like
literally it's like that thing where you have to grab it
from the side and you're right in front of it Oh my god.
And then gotta go like a little bit.
A little bit to your left and then forward.
Don't floor it!
Just a little bit.
I'm not!
Okay.
Keep going a little bit forward.
Pinching.
A little bit to your left.
And then forward.
I won't let me go left anymore.
Hold on.
Oh shoot.
Okay, hold on.
Oh god.
Why can't we just go outside?
Okay, hold on.
Okay, now go left.
Yeah, I know.
Like 90 degrees.
Oh, you're so close.
I'll do that again.
Do the same exact way, guys.
Same thing, okay.
Oh, yeah.
This is tough.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Ow!
They're fine, kiddo.
You're fine, kiddo.
Buck it on.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, back up.
Oh my gosh, the way it spins too much.
Oh, the wheel spins too much when I back up.
It messes me up.
Oh, oh.
Are we okay?
Everything good?
Everyone fine?
Everything's good.
Okay, just back up?
Yeah, I was like a U-turn trying to do.
A U-turn.
Yeah.
Do you remember what a U-turn is, Grandma?
Oh, yeah, you can just U-turn.
You can just U-turn.
Yeah, I could just U-turn.
Okay, okay.
I'll do it.
I'll just U-turn.
Okay.
You're so smart.
Yeah.
It's so simple.
Am I U-turning?
Do you not know what a U looks like?
One second.
Let me go back to the other one.
Oh no, it might be over.
No, it's not.
How do we do the checkpoint thing?
Oh no, we're good, we're good.
Oh no, we're gaming, we're gaming.
We're gaming?
Okay, go straight, go straight.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You're gaming.
It's literally right here.
Hey!
Wait, I got kicked out.
Sorry.
oh no okay let's go forward i want to see what you guys are
talking about anyway a little bit to your right oh there's a
tree in the way oh wow it's like shiny money on the garbage
did you get it no i can see i'm so close which way which way
it's covered by the tree but back up no it's not back up
back up back up can you guys reach it no i can't reach it
back up and then go forward a little bit back up keep
backing up yeah yeah now turn to your right and go forward
yeah yeah oh wrong way right now forward yeah yeah forward
yeah and to your right a little bit a little bit to your
right okay okay okay or close oh okay back up a little bit
and then go right again when you go forward yeah i feel like
is it a collectible or is it for to progress I can't tell.
I just think it's super aggressive because you have to put
the money on top of the bag.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, oh.
You just turn to your right and you'll be able to see it.
You see it, Moku?
I see it.
Okay.
Sharp right.
A sharp right Moku.
I believe in you.
That's not right.
Okay.
Forward and a little bit to your right.
No, you passed it.
You passed it.
Where am I?
Grandma.
Grandma, you're in heaven.
You're dead.
Oh my god.
We're gonna, an hour per each level.
You're like right next to it, but you're far.
Okay, I see, I see, I see, I see.
Okay, you see it?
You can see it off the wrong road.
Oh, you're good.
You're good!
Forward, forward, forward, right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
Like, like, like this.
I don't know.
Oh, so close.
Okay.
I can't reach it.
Oh, who is this?
That's me.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, get in the back with the rest of us.
Oh, we're getting farther away.
Um, hmm.
Right?
No, I think it should back off a little.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, we're getting farther away.
Yeah.
Oh, so.
Oh, oh.
Okay, sorry.
Back, back, back.
You're good.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh my God.
Hey, someone else died again.
I'm outside.
Don't worry about it.
We need the money.
Yeah, we need the cash.
Don't care about.
Oh my God.
We literally, wait.
Oh my gosh, wait.
If you back up, we'll get it.
We'll get it.
Just back up.
Straight.
Oh, someone.
Is someone laying the hawk?
Is someone honking at us in the park?
I like we're bad drivers.
The bloody thingy.
Oh, wait.
Why wouldn't let me reverse?
Oh, you're like- Yeah, turn to your left, actually.
If you turn- if you go- No, never mind.
Just make a sharp left.
Super left.
Super left and go straight.
Like, maybe?
Oh, not left enough, maybe.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I think we're actually upside down.
Oh.
Wait, what's happening?
Are we still upside down?
Yes, we are.
Okay, there we go.
Nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go straight into your right.
Okay.
Oh, what's happening?
You're in front of the statue.
Okay, okay, I can't see you.
Come, Moku, I believe!
Come, Moku, go!
Oh, I can't close.
Forward!
Go forward!
Okay.
Now forward.
Forward, forward.
I don't see it.
Yeah, you're dirty.
great you're doing great okay okay oh stop stop stop stop
stop oh it's so close it's so close is it in front of us or
is it behind it's in front it's in front it's in front of um
just go forward a little bit like edge it edge the engine oh
guys keep edging keep edging i can't reach it no no no wait
back up back up a little tiny bit back up okay Okay, okay.
Mokusa's so stressed.
Okay, now forward, now forward.
Let's go straight.
Straight into the right a little bit, I think.
Okay, straight to the right.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, edge it.
Edge it.
Oh, stop, stop, stop!
Wait, wait, wait.
I can't reach it.
I can't reach that.
No!
the fucking bench oh oh oh okay what we're like next to it
though yeah unless the game wants it to be like pixel
perfect that's crazy oh okay we're gonna drive out of here
oh i think there's an exit right there has to be no way oh
oh wait wait wait wait wait can i can i get it from this Is
it?
It's like a drive-thru?
Yeah, like a drive-thru.
Yeah, yeah!
Oh, I can't reach it.
It's too far!
It has to be so close!
I can't reach it!
Do we like throw coins at it?
Oh, oh my god, what if you have to put the coin inside the-
No way!
Okay, okay, okay, I think I- Just go forward, edge it.
Edge it?
Stop, stop, stop it!
You see it?
Okay, a little bit more, just a little bit more.
Can you grab it?
I can't ride, grab it.
Can I grab it?
Can you grab it?
Yeah, can you grab it?
Uh, is there?
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
I'm gonna lower my windows.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Oh my god, why are we shaking?
Oh!
Okay, here you guys go.
Oh.
Okay.
I think we need to, we need to put it in front of the...
Yeah, we have to put it on the statue.
On the statue.
No way.
Okay.
Yeah, so go forward and right.
We're so close.
You're doing good.
You're doing awesome.
I love when the windshield wipers just come on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's very like old.
Oh, God.
Uh-oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I see it.
It's like flashing red now.
It's like, beep, beep, beep.
Give me money.
Put it here.
I need the money.
Where's the statue?
Oh.
Then we all need money.
Eh.
Okay.
Oh.
Are we close?
Um, there's like something collision in the background.
It's going crazy.
Oh, there's the cars, I think.
A little bit back.
Okay, back up to your left.
Okay.
So go right.
Right.
Okay.
Okay, kind of cool.
Back up more.
Just keep, go back up straight.
Okay.
Just straight up, back up.
And then stop.
Oh, okay, okay, good.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then go forward.
Just go forward.
Straight.
I don't know.
Okay.
Wait.
lause, okay, a little bit just a little Oh, yeah, keep
going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Engin, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're so close!
Let's go, start!
Do one of...
Okay, move through.
No!
No one can not throw the pesticide!
Omen!
Are you getting it?
No, no, no, no, no, I can't.
Go forward a little bit.
Okay, one more.
Just one more time.
Okay, one more time.
Nope, one more time.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Right.
Oh, wait, wait.
Yeah!
Wait, what's happening?
What's it doing?
Oh, he broke the gate, I think, back there.
Oh, yeah, he did.
But what happened to the statue?
I think it fell and like broke the...
Yeah, he like dashed.
Oh to the right!
Hard right, hard right.
Right, edge it.
I will I will.
Why do you keep saying edgy?
It seems to be working.
A little more, a little more, a little more.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop!
Oh, stop!
right straight right straight yeah yeah yeah okay straight
no you're gonna run into the wall yeah a little bit a little
bit this way oh so clear back up okay so okay oh you see it
you see it oh no no i don't see it okay i'm gonna to the
right a little and floor it to the right a little and floor
it oh not enough to the right we're gonna run it to the Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's always Mogu that gets us into the situation.
Yeah, I don't.
You don't have to, I'm gonna do this.
Okay.
Oh, wait, we're out.
We're out.
Go for it.
Floor.
Go straight.
Just go.
Don't stop.
Don't stop for anything.
Just go.
Don't stop.
Just keep going.
Wait!
Okay, so close.
Oh!
Oh.
No!
Oh!
Go right, go right, go right, left, left!
I ran over!
He ran over the cough!
Okay, go right, go no!
Go straight!
Go left!
They're- Oh god damn, he's dead.
Someone died?
Oh, nice.
Who's honking?
Who's honking at me?
I think it's the cop.
It's grandpa.
Wait, if you back up, you'll hit like five people.
It'd be really... Oh, there they go.
There they go.
Mint!
Yeah!
Oh, we ran into a hole.
Keep going?
And we ran into a tree.
Force it?
Of course it!
Okay, a little bit to your left and then go straight.
Okay.
Okay, go straight, straight, straight!
Straight!
Good, good, good, good.
Go, go, go!
Let's go!
Oh my gosh, this is so beautiful!
I'm gonna drive slowly so that we don't flip.
This is not slow.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Who cares about going slow?
Oh, checkpoint!
Floor it!
I'm flooring it!
Oh my god, this is such...
Oh my god.
so much progress we really did make so much progress yeah we
did we might we're almost close i think oh okay oh right and
then forward that's the last thing in the pamphlet it says
to go to what's the pamphlet where are we marvin's mystery
meet oh i see it's right in front of us oh we're gonna flip
there we go nice oh i think we went in the water what the
hell yeah there's a bridge here oh there's a bridge just go
go who cares about traffic Wait, why are we reversing?
Why are we reversing?
Oh, I think the bridge starts going up.
Or something, maybe?
So you just have to keep going.
Just keep going.
Oh, we did it.
And a break, maybe?
Oh.
There's traffic right in front of you.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay, good music.
That was so close.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, it won't let me.
It won't.
Oh, oh.
Maybe, or...
What's happened?
Let me click on the key.
Oh, maybe it like periodically forces you to...
To change.
Yeah.
Go!
Oh, go?
Oh, here you go!
Am I safe?
Just answer your question.
Tell me when.
Okay.
When?
No, no, no, no.
This part is always so hard.
This part's difficult, yeah.
This part's really hard, yeah.
Wait, am I going reverse?
Oh, you're going back.
Wait, I lost my Prendel.
Where is it?
My team's- No, it's right here, it's right here.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I can't grab it.
Can someone- It's right there.
Grab it.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, oh, where?
Oh.
Where are we?
Go, go, go.
Go?
No.
Oh.
It's why is this so slow?
Oh my god, oh my god!
I knew this?
This green light sucks!
Crash that!
Cross it!
Go!
Oh my god!
We did it!
We're doing it!
I didn't know there was a second intersection.
Oh it's hot.
Are we okay?
We're okay team!
don't worry about it we did we did yeah just this one left
oh whoops oh wait you're back sometimes it puts you in
reverse for some reason oh oops sorry I tried breaking the
brake pads are like so bad now oops we're on fire again
sorry also there's no brake pad because there's no brake
yeah here's your brake it's right here oh that's why wait
can you throw it again I can't get it.
I don't know where is it.
Oh, let me get it.
That's why I wasn't breaking.
I'm trying to get it.
I can't get it anymore.
I'll just go straight then.
Oh.
I love this version of frog.
I hate it.
I don't know.
I found the tunnel.
It's right there on the left.
I can't get it.
Oh, yeah, you got the windshield wiper.
Windshield wiper?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
What?
Uhh!
Wee, weee, wee, woo, woo!
Wee, woo, woo!
That's like a 720!
Wait, oh, wait, that's the Prindle?
Oh my gosh.
I need to break you guys!
I can't get it!
Oh, right here, right here!
Where?
Oh!
I tossed it onto the front seat.
The front seat floor.
The right seat.
The passenger seat floor.
I can't reach it.
I can't see it.
Oh.
Nope, that's a windshield.
Or that's the window.
You closed?
The lid.
What lid?
What are you talking about?
What's the lid?
Oh, no.
right there oh i see oh oh i can grab it yeah yeah here here
throw it throw it oh you're desperate that's the windshield
that's my teeth there's a black thing black thing oh wait
hold on oh you know what we're just gonna it'll toss it
around until until it comes back oh i found it Oh my god!
Wait, what is this?
What is this?
It's in the front seat, pass it like from the floor.
That was it.
I can't get it!
That's my thingy that...
I got it!
Hold on!
Oh, oh I got it, I got it!
I got it!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, finally!
It's with the lights.
Okay, tell me when to go.
Okay, good luck.
This is the hardest one.
Start now.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Oh wait wait, wait, hold up.
Oh wait, hold up.
You're cooking, you're cooking!
Oh, okay okay, we bumped it.
Okay, back up, back up, back up.
Yeah!
Baby!
Oops.
Oh, okay, yeah, I got more.
You gotta get chicken nuggets!
I'm insane, I'm insane, I'm insane!
Are we going through the drive-through?
Drive-through!
There's a drive-through?
Yeah, forward, right?
Right, right, right.
Oh, ow.
What if I went inside?
Hold on.
You want chicken nuggets or what?
I want chicken nuggets.
Be patient.
I will.
Yeah.
Yep.
Wait, do I need to keep going back up?
Yeah.
Pick up a little bit.
A little bit.
And then right.
Go right.
A little bit and then go through the drive.
We're gonna have chicken nuggets.
Like this?
Yep.
Keep going.
Then go straight.
And then- Yeah, yeah, perfect.
And then, like...
Now what?
Forward and left?
Left?
Oh my god, it's like we're actually going through.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, I see the drive-through!
Drive-through slop!
Oh my god!
Checkpoint!
I want a little toy.
Okay, perfect, perfect, stop.
Okay.
Now what?
Now go right?
Right?
No, go straight.
Straight.
Just go straight.
Okay.
Wait, where do we go in?
Where's the safe?
I'm so hungry.
Drive-through slop!
I see at the slop!
Yay!
Am I going still?
Just like two steps, two steps.
And then luck.
Unless?
All right good.
Oh my god.
She's so good.
Oh my god!
Order here!
Oh I see!
I see!
I see it!
I can't lose it!
I'm sorry!
I see it!
I can score it!
Oh my god, is that why we need the coins?
Hello.
I think someone needs to...
Oh- Can I get a...
Oh!
Oh, I want you to look like a...
Hello?
I want up, I want down, I want left, and I want right.
Do I pull up more?
No, there's a car.
Guys, order.
Did you guys order?
Why do you get him?
Are we supposed to throw the coin?
A coin at them?
Or is there something else?
I don't see anything.
I could throw a coin too.
Can I get some fries?
I have some...
You're the one who's driving.
Oh, yeah.
No, it says pay here, like over there, though.
So I don't know if we're supposed to pay here.
Did I do it?
I'm not going to swear at him.
I'm Canadian.
How do you swear?
A space bar?
No, mine's telling me.
Wait, wait.
Um...
I have a mixtape in my mouth.
Get it off me, Grandma.
Teach me how to swear!
Fuck!
Oh, it needs to have the mixtape in your mouth.
Wait, you have to?
Yeah, it's a square.
Oh!
No, it's not a square.
How do you put it up?
No, you need it in your mouth.
What is this?
But how did you put it in your mouth?
Is this like a blinker?
I think you have to shove it in.
No, we don't need those.
I need to shove it in.
shove it into your mouth what does this do maybe have to be
closer to the window to order do we do i have to back up
back up straight and then make a slight left when you go
forward yeah um could i get a six piece nugget meal and uh
oh okay i really want chicken nugget actually oh okay oh
perfect perfect okay maybe we now oh wait we can't actually
order oh we can order I'm getting I'm fooding I'm feeding
I'm feeding no wait wait wait oh chicken nugget all chicken
nugget all chicken nugget all chicken nugget all chicken
nugget why is he shaking his head why doesn't he want
chicken nugget sir We're out we're out Hold up what is there
like an order we have to do do we have to do left right
burger fry try that drink burger fry order from top to
bottom drink burger oh oh drink oh my god nope okay drink
burger nope drink drink burger fry okay i'll do it i'll do
it okay ready no i got i got it drink burger fry no okay go
forward we didn't get chicken nuggets oh we can oh we didn't
even let us get chicken nuggets didn't even like chicken
nuggets they said pull forward let's go okay now now it's
kobe kobe time kobe okay okay okay okay i'm pretty sure i
can pay i have four and have a coin are we good more yeah
i'm good yeah forward i got a coin right now i have my order
wrong i'll crash out oh yeah yeah perfect perfect perfect
perfect two coins two coins okay oh a little bit more a
Yeah, okay.
Okay, go go.
Go Mogu.
There's another, is there another coin?
Oh, oh.
I don't have one.
I don't see it on runaway.
I see our coin in the front.
Oh, I see it right here.
I see it right there.
Do you see it, Nusko?
Next to grandma?
Next to grandma.
Why can't it, it doesn't reach.
Do we need to hand it to him?
I think you just hand it to his hand.
Okay, where's the coin though?
Do we use all the coins?
No, they respawn.
They respawn.
Oh, wait, they're in the front seat.
um can you give it to him you got him do i have to go closer
do i back up and then be closer maybe okay okay yeah they
they want you to be really close that's how this whole game
is they just they have to be super oh so close that's so
good is it good no way oh oh you got one you got one you got
one we got one we got one okay one more one more I don't see
another Oh, I see it under the sea Oh, right there Oh, there
Okay, and then He needs a steering wheel Oh, a steering
wheel Yeah, he needs a steering wheel How do I give that to
him?
Uh, right click the steering wheel, maybe Oh, okay No way
Can you give it to me?
Uh-oh, wait It dropped out of the car And now I don't have a
Wait, did it?
Oh, it respawned, it's fine, it's fine Here, I'll give it to
you guys I'll give it to you guys Okay, okay Oh, just
kidding No.
There you go.
Oh, just kidding.
I got it.
You got it.
Wait how am I supposed to drive?
The guy's still asking for a steering wheel.
Oh no, we responded he responded.
They responded.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Here you go.
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Oh my.
Oh we're gonna die.
We're gonna die in here.
This is literal hell.
This is, this is it.
Get us out!
Gass it!
Gass it?
I have no steering wheel!
Okay.
Oh, I guess you just gotta go forward because there's
nothing really out.
Oh, I can't wait.
I have it in park and I can't move.
Oh, yes, I can.
Oh, God, I can't see.
Let's go, whoa.
I can't see.
See anything.
It's crazy.
I don't know what's happening.
Where am I?
What's happening?
I don't know.
I just see colors.
I can't see anything!
I'm a little...
I think we just have to get out.
How do we get out?
On the right, on the right.
I can't steer.
We have to eat it.
Oh, are we supposed to eat it?
I think we're supposed to eat it.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
There you go.
Is there a steering wheel in the car again?
Oh, it's the pizza.
Oh my god.
Here, here, here, here.
Grandma, use the pizza.
Oh, the pizza.
oh my wait this isn't oh this is so evil wait it hides how
much your wheels are turned down no oh evil how do we get
out where's the out oh i see it we have to back up we have
to back up back up it's on our right or you're closer
reversing out oh wait like this yeah yeah yeah keep going
back back no yeah oh we We had a checkpoint.
Oh, nice.
We're not done yet.
Oh my god.
I know.
Kill me.
Please, I'm done with this.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please let me leave.
Put me out of this misery.
I don't even know.
Oh, trip.
How is that the checkpoint?
What are we supposed to do next?
I think you're supposed to- What's the last thing we need?
What's the last thing we need?
Oh, no, no, no.
I see it behind us.
Behind us.
the alleyway why do we have to go to the alleyway oh no wait
can we i'm gonna reset wait reset restart checkpoint okay
okay yo where are we do i just go forward go forward a
little bit turn left oh yeah there's a shortcut in the
alleyway that's not us turn which way are we supposed to go
left Left and then left left What the hell?
Oh, it's forcing me to switch with one of you.
Wait, we have an engine!
A check engine error!
There you go.
Oh shit!
Good luck!
Ah!
Stop laughing!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, grandma.
I just couldn't get enough of being in that seat.
Oh, just a little bit more.
I like how we're electing Pazuzu.
Oh my god, this is so difficult.
Wait, this is gonna be so tough.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
Oh, shit.
No, hard right, hard right.
Wait, 1-800-555.
I'm always tired.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, grandma.
Grandma.
I got a lot.
You don't have to get ready if you stay ready.
oh shit oh the lights are my oh my god we're good we're good
we're good it's so typical with the pizza wait is that the
owl i want to go to the dinosaur store oh the dinosaur oh a
rhinosaurus red oh wait that's so smart that's okay
Left!
I'm breaking- Oh, I was like, that's why I'm not breaking.
We're back to the checkpoint, I think.
You could just restart at the checkpoint.
Do you want to...
Like, to the right?
Or left?
Left?
Oh, no!
No, no, no.
Okay, okay, okay, yeah.
I'm gonna eat some food.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, okay.
Okay, good, good, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
A little- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're gaming.
We're gaming?
We're gaming somehow.
And then...
Left!
turn a little bit like a micro pp left micro pp yeah micro
pp left like that okay okay a little bit forward like this
yeah yeah yeah you're doing really good what the hell and
then left okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah twisty twisty turny oh shit now this way
right right right you're doing good yeah yeah backing off my
god i'm doing i'm game it i'm locking in no this is you're
really good holy oh my god oh my god nice yeah that was
awesome okay okay it says road closed where do i go left or
right oh my god we can't see i don't know i can't see from
my my i think you just gotta go straight okay oh wait i
think this is
another hour i love the average speed is three three miles
per hour we're response 28 we respond 28 times oh we got
chocolate chocolate bar our whole car is becoming food oh
we're in the subway we're at the subway oh this kid looks
how long is the day
The kid be like, why was he in English before?
Now he's not.
Yeah, I know, right?
All right, grandma.
Okay, let me drive through the subway.
Drive through the subway, Prindle.
Prindle!
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Am I cooking?
I'm cooking.
Cooking.
You're cooking?
Yeah, this is good, this is good.
Oh nice, to the right.
To your right.
Oh, there's tickets.
There's a pedestrian.
Oh, there's a pedestrian?
Where is that one?
Hit him.
To the right.
Straight and right.
Straight?
Yep.
Right.
Yeah.
Wait, where did he go?
Like that right?
here?
A little bit more.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, wait, wait, yeah, no.
Oh, we do need to buy the ticket, though.
Wait, actually, stop here?
Yeah.
Damn, I made it right on time.
Hold on.
Oh, I gotta take it.
I gotta take it.
Oh.
Uh, here.
Oh, you have to put the...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
Oh, I'm gonna roll my window down and tell him he's gonna
die.
You're gonna die.
We're gonna get you.
Your next buddy.
Am I not supposed to put it in?
Is it in?
Uh...
Does this say anything?
This doesn't say anything?
I'm gonna look for...
Do you want me to back up?
No, no, no, it's perfect.
It's perfect.
I just can't find a coin.
Oh, we need a coin.
There is something glowing behind us.
Yeah, there's a bicycle behind us.
Do you want me to go back?
Yeah.
Let's check it out.
Just like a little bit.
Oh, go back a little?
Yeah, do you see the glowing bicycle?
It says buy your tickets.
I'm pretty sure we're supposed to.
Like this?
What is this bike for?
Oh, I see the coins are in the front.
We escape from Grandma's wrath and we ride the bike home.
Grandma.
I don't want to go on the third rail.
What's the third rail?
You wouldn't like it.
how you turn into a ghost if that's where you guys are then
I would gladly become a ghost song is kind of bobbing okay
okay go forward go forward just a little bit stop do you
have the coins you got it oh oh I yeah I missed here I
missed I can't see oh it's in the front grandma it's on the
front Can I toss it?
Yeah, try tossing it on your end.
How do I know if my window's down?
You roll them.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's down.
It's like really obvious when it's up.
Oh, I missed it.
Like this?
Oh.
Did it?
Oh, wait, I heard something.
Oh, I think so.
I think so.
Oh, did I go forward now?
To the right.
Forward and to the right.
Okay.
What the hell?
Forward first or right first?
Both at the same time.
Like this?
Yeah.
Wait, what's that written on the wall over there?
Do I go forward now?
Wait, what does this say?
Yeah, forward.
It's like shining.
Yeah, something's on the wall.
Left.
Oh, we gotta put it in the...
Yeah, we gotta put it in the...
Oh, God.
In our little...
Yeah.
Well, I'm gonna take this out of my mouth.
I'll take it.
Take it out with your mouth.
Just use your arms, forehead.
Like this?
Am I cooking?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
One mint sign now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just give.
Put the ticket.
Stop, stop, stop, stop!
Where's the ticket?
I don't know.
What is the ticket?
There's a coin, there's a mixtape.
Mixtape?
Is this a red thing?
No, that's probably not.
No, that's in the instructions.
Where'd the ticket go?
Who has- Did we get a ticket?
Did we?
Uh, I only see this magazine thing.
Another coin.
I don't see a ticket.
Did we get a ticket?
IBS.
There's nothing in the glove compartment?
Wait, uh, Dusty, when you threw in the coin, did it give you
a ticket?
I got no idea.
it sounded like something happened though share back up and
try again music like the music right yeah there was like
there was something yeah yeah it made like a sound yeah
otherwise we all wouldn't have thoughts that it worked I
think oh wait was that just a subway noise noise you guys
hear it well back it up alright grandma I don't want to
drive anymore.
I'm driving.
What do you mean?
I'm the one who's driving.
I want to go.
Where's the ticket thing?
I can't see.
To the right.
I mean, sorry.
To your left.
Other right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you hit him.
You hit him.
Oh, he's so dead.
He's so dead.
I want to see what this says.
Oh, I see it.
It's like behind us, right?
Or where is it?
This is your left.
To your left.
Back up a little bit.
Gotcha.
stop okay if beyond stop stop stop stop stop wait wait this
might be perfect give me a cool oh my god give me the cool
right in front of me grab it grab it and give it to me okay
do it do the thing roll down wait can you back up like us
the tiniest bit okay yeah yeah yeah like this one more like
this you're not backing up at all oh it's on neutral one
minute like this yeah uh one more one more okay perfect wait
is your window at all is it your windows not down your
window is not down my babe here you go there you go nobody
saw that oh my gosh it's like i think it's got to be pixel
perfect.
Oh, no.
I can't even see.
Can you guys press up and then see?
Like, if there's a hole?
Yeah, there's a hole.
Oh my god.
Come on, every hole is a goal.
You're hitting like the...
You're hitting the top.
Do I need to go inside?
Oh, I got- I dropped the ticket on the- Oh, I got it!
I got the trade ticket!
Oh, yay!
Okay, good, good, good, good, good, good.
Okay, now where do I go?
Where do I go?
I can back off a little?
Back up.
Back up?
This way.
Yeah, this way.
I want to go to...
Where are we going?
I want to go to a maid cafe.
Yeah!
I want to...
Wait, can you keep backing up like crazy, like all the way?
I want to see what this says.
Oh, stop now?
Oh, okay.
There's like a secret.
Can you pull forward just a tiny bit?
Okay, let me put Moku back.
There we go.
You can find me...
Move forward a little bit?
Oh yeah, there is a secret.
If anyone would like to buy me a new B-phone or a Banana Ink
Second Skin virtual reality, headset you can find me under
the bridge i am the one wearing a jacket made of old
magazines thank you okay that's all i wanted to write where
do we go to the left all the way to the left left left left
okay good good good oh okay wait stop oh oh never mind wait
oh there's another one yeah there's a second one go back a
little a little bit like this like this yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay and then what and then street a little bit inch forward
no inch forward no no right oh right or left wait i don't i
can't see anything what are you guys doing What the fuck?
No?
Now you can go forward.
Yeah, now you go forward.
I know I'm perfect baby.
Edge, edge, edge.
To the... Hang right, hang right.
Oh, good, good, good.
You're so good.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Just a little bit back.
Yep.
A little more?
A little bit?
There we go.
Oh, perfect.
Did it work?
Did you do it?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Get ticket.
Put your ticket in.
Oh, do we have to get closer?
Oh my god, it's one of these.
Maybe.
Someone else do it.
It's on the seat.
Oh, where is it?
Um.
Oh, I think we have to be closer.
Can you go closer?
Okay, so you want me to back up a little bit and go right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Turn to the right.
Like this?
Okay.
To the forward?
An inch?
Just forward or do you want me forward right?
Forward right.
Like that?
And then more.
A little bit more.
Like that?
A little more.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No more.
We're getting...
Yay!
Woo!
You're gonna go to your right and then...
Then you go to my right.
Right and then go to the left.
Ooh.
We will be subscribed under funded public transit services.
Oh, please.
Nope.
Oh, are we right in the train?
No, the key is blinking.
Oh, yeah, you have to switch this up and then...
Okay.
Let's go!
Okay, left, left, left, left!
Left, left, left, left!
Yay!
Go, no no, go, wait, go, go, go, wait, go, wait, wait!
Right, right!
Okay, okay, okay, eeah!
Go right.
Go left, left, left, left.
Left, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Straight, straight, straight, straight.
The wheel back.
Keep going, straight, straight, straight.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Keep going, keep going.
Just keep going forward.
Keep going, this way, this way.
Yeah, yeah, good, good, good, good, good.
Okay.
Why is it so slow?
Oh.
Oh, the pedal fell off.
The pedal fell off.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
the title of chocolate bar oh it is our whole car is turning
into candy yay oh oh oh oh oh my spine hi welcome
nope nope you're going to office direction i hope you're
going backwards oh where are we no no you're going the wrong
way you're going the wrong way You're completely going the
wrong way.
Yeah, you're going the wrong way.
Yeah, turn hard right.
Turn hard right.
Like super hard.
Rock hard.
Oh, come on.
Vogue, Vogue.
We don't.
Hard right.
Okay.
Not hard enough.
Oh my god.
Ow.
Oh no.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm out of the car.
Did you say that?
Oh, I am out of bounds.
Nice.
Okay.
Now back up straight and then go left.
Turn the other way when you're backing up.
Yeah.
You're perfect there you go.
Back up straight and then left.
I think the perfect is kind of a...
Alright.
Now to the left.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Good, good, good, good, good girl.
Good girl, good girl.
Good girl.
Go back up, back up, back up, back up, back up!
Oh, we hit a checkpoint!
Oh.
Where are we?
What did I do?
Oh, go straight now into the...
Oh, oh, I'm freezing.
Oh, oh, sorry.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, shit.
Thank you.
Here you go.
Okay.
Do we go to the grave?
What do we do now?
Wait, wait, wait.
I need to defrost my windows.
Okay.
Now forward- I'm chilly!
I'm chilly!
And then turn right.
Hi, chilly.
I'm dust.
Oh, turn right, turn right.
Oh, oh, wait, wait, wait.
I'm sorry, man.
Here you go.
That's not me.
But thanks.
That was me.
That was weird.
Where are you going?
Yeah, there's so many arrows everywhere.
Okay.
I think it's like, you have to go in there and it's like a
little bit, not a maze, but kind of like a snake, you know?
it's like a snake oh solid snake wait did you have a break
uh i don't need i don't need one i did lose it but i don't
need one that's okay you don't need the what the brick oh
okay cool yeah just like we don't need windows yeah we only
need each other where do we go okay to the left where where
bogu was going and then backed up and then but then it says
there's like a right my arrows are saying to go left i don't
know where i'm going no we go inside there we go in there we
go in yeah we go in there okay oh there you go oh there you
go oh no no no no no i'm sorry i'm sorry oh can you guys oh
yeah oh i'm just there you go thank you thanks okay so you
need to turn Okay, wait, maybe I do need my brake.
Did you guys see my brake?
Where's the Chocolate Bar?
Oh, it is a chocolate bar?
A chocolate bar.
I don't see it.
Oh, I see it in the front seat.
Oh, I see it.
It's in the front.
Okay, now let the back block.
I see it.
Okay, go forward.
No, no, no, don't go forward.
Oh, oh Oh, wait.
Yeah, keep going the way you're going?
Yeah, keep going.
how yeah now now turn left turn left here okay oh i see it i
see it's those line thingies like oh no no stop stop stop
you missed it you missed it you missed it oh okay okay mooku
actual all verses i know i know i thought i thought we were
playing a game i didn't think it was that
I'm the girl.
I'm going in the right lane.
Okay, okay.
Yes, turn left.
Turn left.
Okay, and forward.
Left and forward.
Am I turning left?
Chad, am I turning left?
I don't know anymore.
Oh!
Dude, it's hard.
The pizza makes it harder.
It does.
Because you can't see your wheels anymore.
Okay, wait.
This is fine, though.
Keep going left.
You'll turn around.
Okay.
Yeah, like that.
Oh my gosh.
It is a good boy.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, no, no, no.
There you go.
Oh, close, close, close.
I can't see anything.
We can't either.
Okay, am I supposed to...
Super frosted or is it super hot?
It's hot.
Yeah, you need to make it colder.
There you go.
Oh, too cold.
Too cold.
Let me know.
good good good i put the windows down i'm calling for help
help me s-o-s all right back up back up straight and then
you'll go to your right you'll turn up make a hard right yes
yeah back up straight okay keep going back up straight back
up straight just a little bit more just a little bit more
okay all right now hard right hard right turn it as far as
you can to the right don't floor it
Yeah, that one And I'm right Right right right Right No, no,
no No, no Okay, okay, okay Okay, I see I see Grandma sees
Grandma sees I believe Moku grandma I believe I believe Moku
If I ever go visit you I hope you're not Picking me up From
the airport Oh Let me help you Okay, forward and right
Forward a little bit Then go right I'd like to go back From
the car Thank you I can't Ormo I don't see You're dead body
anymore no no i'm back oh good good good good good good go
right right right right right right and forward right yeah
yeah right right right oh wait wait wait wait stop oh yes
back up a little oh yeah just a little bit uh like a teeny
tiny no oh stop break break break i got another four four
four oh my god are you kidding me oh nice nice nice oh we're
great you're doing good you're doing good okay now go look
and then tiny yeah why are we why are we
Vogue, you have to do this.
This is your challenge that you must be.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, no, no, you're giving.
You're giving.
Just a little bit more.
Am I?
Wait, why can't I go straight?
Because you're bumping into the rail.
You have to go back a little.
Just like a little bit.
Okay.
You're so close.
Okay, now stop.
And go to your left.
Hard left.
Like, oh my...
Wait, really?
Like this left or this left?
What?
You're left.
Like, forward, forward left.
Forward left.
Oh.
This left?
You
have to do this.
This is you.
could do this this is your training this is your training
this is your training you could do it oh shoot okay just go
back okay forward left yeah yeah yeah good good good oh nice
nice nice now back up oh no no no no no oh no oh yes yes
okay perfect perfect okay nice you just have to go left you
all okay now go left hard left hard left like mega hard so
if we ever together your other left right that's
counterclockwise right guys oh no oh no
okay back off a lip if you have to if you have to put up
your hands and you you hold up your right your index finger
and your thumb and then the left hand will look like an L at
the right hand.
Like, I go backwards.
Oh, wait, wait.
You're doing it.
I don't know how, but.
I don't know.
Go ahead.
You do it.
No, she...
Oh, yeah, she did.
Go right.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Go forward and right.
A little bit to your right.
Just a little bit.
Like a smidge.
Like a dash of right.
I don't even think she needs to go to her right.
Okay, Anita, go straight.
Yeah, go straight.
Floor it, floor it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Checkpoint.
Okay, now go make it right.
Where do you go right?
Make it right.
Go straight, go straight, go straight.
Wait, wait, hold on.
Good, good, good.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I need to put the wheel on.
A little bit to your left.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
No.
Why did you reverse?
I don't know.
so bad this is so bad yes yes okay okay okay no no no no do
the same thing do the same thing as before goes forward and
left i don't think she knows what she can oh oh no we had
the perfect turn we had the perfect turn yeah you were doing
so good I'm gonna I need a pee over your back.
I really need a piss.
I'm gonna piss myself Okay, just a little bit back.
Just yeah, just back up a little bit Just a little bit.
I really want to spindle.
Oh, I found it.
Okay.
Oh Okay, okay, wait hold up.
Um Okay, you're gonna want to go far the left and straight
the left right right Oh, sorry.
Hard ride.
Hard.
But back up again.
Yeah.
And then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hard.
It needs to be harder.
Harder.
Hard.
Oh, okay.
When you...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
Why?
Okay.
Oh, geez.
A little bit.
Yeah, you could, good, good.
Oh my God, you're gaming.
Yeah, you're gaming?
Okay.
And then...
And then a little bit back.
Like a little bit?
Yeah, a little bit back?
Okay.
Okay, stop, stop, stop.
Yeah, yeah.
Turn hard right.
Hard, hard, hard, hard, hard, hard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now straight, straight, straight, straight, straight,
straight.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Your wheel is straight.
Floor it!
Yeah!
That was so gentle.
Where are we going?
Okay, a little bit back.
No, no, you're so close.
Yeah, you're really close.
You're really close.
Oh, I have to turn left here.
Yes.
Oh, I have to.
Oh, I don't think you're going there.
Are we there yet?
Oh, other way!
Other way!
Actually, I think you can back.
back up back up like go back up straight yeah just back up
you're oh nice nice nice nice keep backing up like turn it
the other way and back up yeah yeah yeah yeah oh nice nice
okay okay right straight a little straight straight straight
hit that guy kill him you're gonna okay you're gonna die
today mister i hope you enjoyed your pizza oh stop stop stop
okay now go forward Left.
Left.
Don't, don't, don't.
Turn.
Yep.
There you go.
Keep turning.
Yeah.
Okay.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
That was on purpose.
It was.
I was so stressful.
Get your ass.
That was on purpose.
You're gonna go straight and hard right.
I'm going to wear the lines as...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
We're so proud of you.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait, a little to the left, a little to the left.
Oh my god.
Right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right,
right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right,
right, right, right.
You have to see my edge.
I was like, wait, where are you?
Wait, how did you, how did you do this?
Wait, uh, she parallel parked.
She parallel parked in this.
You're so close, Mogo.
You got this.
Mogo, Mogo, go.
All right.
Mogo, Mogo.
Okay.
You're gonna need to reverse turn.
Not...
You know how the K turned?
What?
Uh, other...
Other way, I think.
Right?
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
No, no, no.
No, the other...
Turn the wheel the other way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go, there you go.
And then go.
Yeah, yeah, and then...
Oh.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh No, make a left, make a left,
make a left.
I know, I know.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna...
How are you doing this, Moku?
I don't understand.
Moku!
You're so close.
Moku, you're so close.
Just trust me.
Wait, where are you like...
You know, like, those things where you try to put the key in
the door and you keep missing?
Oh, wait, you're so close.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going!
Why?
Why did you prefer?
I'm like, I love you!
Girl, girl.
God, girl, what the fuck?
Wait, wait, wait, you're saying, you're...
You're Pryndal, you're Pryndal.
My Pryndal.
Right there, right there.
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, I...
Oh, how do you keep doing this?
No, I'm running.
Okay, where's the...
Okay.
Oh, it's too cold.
It's too cold.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
Okay.
So what are you gonna do?
I'm gonna go get some water.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
You know how to do a donut?
I need you to do a Donut.
Where is it?
Okay, okay, okay.
No, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, you're getting closer technically.
Uh, okay, okay, left, left, left.
Okay, okay.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay, okay.
Back up a little bit.
Okay, back up a little bit.
Okay.
No, I think I'm gonna make...
Killing move.
Go forward.
Poo, just forward.
Yes.
Put the wheel back straight.
I don't know how to kill a back street.
Yeah, okay, you did it!
Yeah, keep going.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
I don't know.
Nothing's happening.
You keep going.
You're not controlling it, girl.
Okay, never mind.
park up.
Moko, please.
Okay.
Oh my god, you did it!
Yeah!
Okay.
Okay, now you have to back up and then go right.
Okay, can someone find my brakes?
Brakes.
Uh, brakes.
I think it's in the passenger floor seat, like floor.
I can't reach that.
I'm not tall enough.
Oh, just like press your, press the D key.
Anything you can like lean.
There you go.
Can you reach it?
See.
That's a mixtape.
There you go.
Found it.
Okay.
You just need to back up straight.
You're doing...
Just a little bit.
Okay.
And then I think it's right.
And then, okay.
Stop, stop.
And then go right.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Okay, now go straight.
Straight, straight, straight.
Yeah!
Good job.
Good, good, good.
Good, good.
What?
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm feeling speed.
I don't care if I die today.
Okay, go right, go, right, go, right, go, right, right,
right, right, right.
Oh.
Who was that?
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I'm driving again, I guess.
Dusty, old lady driving.
My way.
I'm supposed to drive.
I think you have to like avoid the what's uh I found the
Prindle I got you it's over it's uh wait um I got you wait I
got you hold on I got you we might be gaming oh never mind I
don't wait oh we don't need the Prindle Hey grandma what
just happened the train came isn't that so cool every three
minutes
am I we're both I don't know where we are I'm dead so I'm
alive mint is definitely dead yeah I'm dead how do I chillin
she's okay I've really been chilling I can't move yeah I
can't either how do I go back to the checkpoint um you're
doing okay there mint yeah I'm okay I'm one with the dash
dash up the dash I think we're up the ceiling how do I how
do we go back to the checkpoint because I can't turn oh here
oh there you go there we go okay so I go left or right you
go right right oh I'm missing the prindle oh I got it throw
thanks me oh There you go.
Eh.
Okay.
So I just go forward and right, right?
Yeah.
Forward and right.
Be careful of the train.
Um, here comes the train.
You should remember about our pedestrians.
Oh, don't- Can we just have the train go- To the left?
Push us forward?
Like this?
Oh, no, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hang right.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, go forward.
Now.
Go forward?
Oh, it's not going forward.
Oh, here comes the train!
Here comes the train!
Oh, this is impossible.
No, this is actually impossible.
this is impossible i won't do this i won't satisfy their
games i what how does this do this this is the worst oh my
god okay okay maybe you can push us forward oh oh my god oh
to the left oh it alternates left and right track so yeah
it's like um the worst
this is the worst the fuck is happening okay uh you want to
ride to your to the left side of i don't have my printer
anymore oh here you go thank you there you go grandma thanks
sweetheart grandma why do you look so hairy today hairy what
you speak to your grandma like this
You can't move forward for some reason.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is the Prindle not?
Wait, do you have your gas pedal?
Oh, your gas?
You're missing the gas.
Oh, where's my break?
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
You got it?
There you go.
I got it.
Okay, I'm going.
Let's go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, go.
The left?
Hug, no.
Hug the right.
Wait, are we actually supposed to do that?
That's insane.
What?
my steering wheel okay where am i alive i we're at top of
the track i've i just see a black screen but i can tell
we're alive what uh i can't see anything i can't see
anything i can't see men i can see you are you guys dead
okay yeah you guys how do i reset oh restart checkpoint
right Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Oh.
Okay, I have my brakes, my Prindle's here.
Okay, let's get going.
Let's go!
Right?
Wait, why didn't she turn?
Oh, wait.
It's over.
It's hard to relax.
I'm ready to die.
Wait, you're going the wrong way.
You're going the wrong way.
Slop.
That's what this game is.
Yeah, it is.
It's supposed to be a slop.
Wait, you might be right.
Forward, straight.
Forward, forward, forward.
Grandma!
Grandma, you're grabbing me, not the car!
What?
Oh, I can't see anything, actually.
I can't see anything.
We can't see anything.
Oh, time to die.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, thank you.
Wait, can you make it warm in here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yes.
I don't think we're gonna back through this, guys.
No.
Wait, can I try?
Yeah, you can try.
Switch.
Change places.
Oh.
Yeah, you're missing the break.
I wasn't before.
Um, I don't see it back here.
I don't see the break.
Did I ever tell you guys that sometimes at drive-thrues, I
roll down my window a little bit and I just whisper, help
me, the best.
Baba hates when I do this.
Why would he hate it?
I know, right?
He tells me to stop doing this.
Here, I threw it to you.
You did?
Yeah.
That was your gas.
Oymo, the train is coming.
Oh, it's over.
Oymo, we're gonna get run over.
We're gonna get run over.
Alright, you step guys.
Grandma's gonna get ran over by a reindeer, except the
reindeer looks like a car.
Am I not running?
Where am I going?
pedal on yeah you're also running into a wall wait i already
have the gas pedal though no that that's your brake pedal no
the e is a gas yeah i already have an e oh i have another e
what's the other there you go that's so stupid gaming you
gotta reverse and turn to the right yeah remember oima this
is another drive okay i think i'm better than bobo
I might, I'm gonna want to drive.
I think I'm stuck.
I'll try after, you know, I don't want to do this part,
though.
I'm legitimately, wait, am I not stuck?
You are stuck, yeah.
You gotta turn, you gotta go hard right now, hard right.
Forward hard right.
Hard.
Hard rock.
Harder.
Harder, harder, harder.
Now hard right.
Harder.
Harder right.
Like the hardest...
You're just going straight back and forth, sweetie.
You're really good.
Wait, who's in the seat now?
It's me.
Vintos, save us.
Save us, save us.
I don't want to do this part.
I don't want to.
I think I got stunned.
Wait, are we...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I went the wrong way, my bud.
And then you can reverse.
Let's just reverse back.
Yeah, we'll do it backwards.
We'll just do it.
We'll do it in style.
We don't look at cool explosions.
The only thing cool that I like to see is in this car
already.
Where's the train?
It'll come.
Oh, wait.
Awesome.
It always comes.
Oh, shit.
I think that was me.
I'm sorry.
I lost my Prindle.
Can someone please give it to me?
I think I see it.
Dear Prindle, I see it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Did anyone grab it?
I don't know.
You told me to grab all.
And did anyone grab my break?
We're still alive.
It's behind me.
It's on my butt.
Oh no, it's on your butt.
Oh, why are you shoving up your butt?
You're not supposed to let that sanitize at first.
Yes, I will give it to this.
I got it.
now i need my break break okay i see it by i see over here i
got it got it got it is it that yeah i got it wait you got
it here you go oh thank you okay let's do this again baby
only for the most beautiful grandma okay oh wait oh my god
you're so good at this all right tell me when to go left or
right just say oh Whoops, look.
Left, left, left, left, left!
We're trying!
Where am I?
Wait.
Oh my gosh, we're almost out of bounds!
Holy cow!
We're back at the entrance!
It's coming again, I think.
Oh my god.
It's so difficult.
It is.
I don't think we're gonna get through this part, everybody,
But that's fine.
Okay, grab while it goes straight.
Okay, you're going great.
Go straight.
Okay, good, good, good.
Oh, my God.
You're doing so good.
Very straight.
Left, left, left.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, is this pattern right now?
No!
It's over for us!
It's okay.
There's another train coming right.
Maybe I'll see.
Oh, it reset.
It reset.
Oh, it pushes way back into the entrance.
Why did it do that?
Oh, there you go.
Thank you, thank you.
Good, good.
Okay, okay, okay, nice.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, it's cold.
Oh, sorry, my bad.
That's my, I didn't do that.
I swear, there's this, this, this car is haunted or
something.
For real.
Ghost car.
It's like there's two ghosts in here or something.
Like, what the hell?
Oh my god, what?
Why would that happen ever?
That's like the rarest thing ever.
That's crazy.
Try to drive a car.
Yeah, it could never happen.
Okay.
Sorry.
I know I'm driving a little erratically.
Here we go.
I think Omo and I are also probably dead.
Left, left, left, left, left, left, left, left.
Yeah, I think this is pattern recognition.
It's always left.
Right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right.
Oh!
Wait, no, hold up.
Hold up.
Wait, we made it through the first part.
We made it back, back up, back up, back up.
Back up, I'm trying!
Back up!
Yeah, go right, go right, go right.
Yeah, a little bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, good, good.
Oh my God, no way!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we went past the first part.
Uh, we made it to the third part.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
I went the wrong way.
Okay, just go make a hard right.
Yeah.
The rotation on this part is ass.
Okay, go straight.
Go straight.
And then left.
Yeah.
Oh, we did it.
Oh.
Oh, what's happening?
No.
Huh?
What do you mean, no?
Oh, I'm in your lap.
Mwah.
Wait, where do we go now?
Go straight?
Oh, it's a bunch of boxes.
No way.
Oh, this looks so awful.
Okay, go a little bit to your left.
And then, no, back up.
Back up.
Oh.
And then go a little bit to your left.
your left why can't we just run over the box yeah why can't
we just dude those fucking boxes are just filled with cinder
blocks my bad oh man is this truly hell yeah which way do I
go uh left left yeah because there's a box right in front of
you oh oh is there a way to go around oh you have to go
around these oh i gotta go around you might have to back up
back up yeah back up and then a little back up straight back
up straight and oh there you go oh oh sorry so sorry so
sorry it's all the pizza the pizza okay move a little bit to
the right because you're okay oh it's perfect perfect i
think that's good okay there's a ramp there's a ramp a ramp
go straight go straight go straight i'm flooring it i'm
flooring it i'm flooring it oh my god let's go a little bit
let's go on the back are we good oh i think they're all
ramps i do this all ramp
um are we are we are we facing up we're yes we're facing the
ceiling we are are we are we're facing the ceiling oh we
fell off the room can you go i'm gonna reverse Oh, geez.
I think we might have to restart it.
No, no, don't say that.
You can salvage it.
Salvage it.
Okay.
I believe in my wife.
I'm stuck.
Wait, hold on.
Wait.
Maybe a little bit more.
Oh, what is it doing?
Keep going, keep going.
I can't.
Keep placing the...
Is that letting...
Wait, okay, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god.
Let's go, Vito!
Wait, hold on.
Let's try.
Let's try this.
Okay, I go straight.
Or go left.
Like this.
And then when I back up, I go like this.
I go like that.
Yeah.
Yeah, see the plan.
Okay.
Oh.
It kicked me out.
Good luck.
I don't think I can see us.
Good luck, everybody.
Good luck, everybody else.
Who's everyone else?
Oh, is that Oimo?
It is.
Do you want to come back again?
No, no, no.
Is it moving at all?
You tell us.
No?
What?
Because I'm backing up like full speed.
Yeah, it's kind of tricky.
Oh yeah, we're like right on top of something.
Oh, I think we fell off.
Are we restarting?
have to go soon though i have a meeting in a couple minutes
yeah it's getting to have time it's all yeah that's fine ah
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa this game is hell i never want
to touch it again why did we say this would be fun it was
fun with you guys it was fun with you guys thank you also
really hard too it was hard because we did it together holy
cow oh my god i think it was fun because you guys were
playing yeah friendships makes the game friends soft makes
the sloth you know are we kind of the same thing oh wait i
can shoot it out to people's mouth give me give me give me
give me i want to eat more tape I read this Yay, thank you
guys.
Thank you.
I'll see you guys soon.
Yeah, I'm gonna I'll head out then Okay, love you Bye-bye
Bye everyone.
Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Love you.
Bye-bye.
What?
Which?
What did this girl say?
what did you say what did you say hold on I said you're
sometimes like we're bad at leaving calls sometimes we just
have to leave at the same time oh that's true that's true
but I have you have to go meeting yeah that's the only
reason bye
it's true though sometimes just go and I just go and I will
watch common rider together sometimes and and then when
we're trying to end the call we'll be like you love you love
you love you love you love you so yay this game was hard
this game was so sticking hard what the heck oh i have no
none of the customizations oh my god good morning rider But
I had a lot of fun.
I hope you guys did too.
That was craziness.
Minto, kawaiijo, thank you.
Fun group though.
Hope you all played something together again.
Yeah.
Originally, we were going to play that RV there yet game,
but I think all three of them had already played.
And apparently the map stays the same.
So it's only me that hasn't played it before.
the nifty and fun driving lesson we learned things yeah hold
on let me make sure vb and vicky are okay okay i gotta
record some stuff
okay i still had a lot of fun even though the game was very
challenging i put my car driving skills to like the absolute
test now nobody can ever say that i'm a bad driver again
because i felt so powerful i felt so powerful the minto
stays busy how does she do it two streams and two meetings
in one day she's insane how does she do it yeah i have like
wait wait what time are we Am I crazy?
Oh my god, we're meeting in an hour.
Oh,
I was like, oh wow.
Do I have like four hours of meeting today?
No, we're meeting in an hour.
Oh, oops.
Well, that's okay.
I can get some rest for a little bit.
Actually, I have some stuff I need to do before the meeting
too.
So you were legit doing great with driving blind.
Thank you.
yeah time to speed run i could i can handle it i can handle
this whole game all at my own no the power of friendship got
us the real friday whoops saturday night 9 p.m whoops 10 p.m
meeting
good time to rest for a bit yeah i think this is the most
i'll have to rest today so thank you guys thank you thank
you thank you i will see you when I'll see you next.
I'll see you later.
Tomorrow's karaoke.
I'm excited.
We can just...
That will be pretty chill, I think, too.
Yeah, yeah.
I have just a few things that I need left for debut.
I'm waiting on a... I'm waiting on some stuff to come in the
mail.
For me to use.
I have to record some things tomorrow.
But...
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm such a genius.
genius.
There was one part of something that I was making that was
like the most daunting for me and I was like oh my gosh am I
going to be able to do this?
Am I going to be able to complete it in time?
And then I came up with another idea and I was like yeah I'm
so glad I'm a genius.
I'm so glad I'm a genius.
Karaoke is there going to be an announcement?
Yeah the announcement will be that you should come watch
Denso2.exe on Friday.
For real now, I'm gonna head out.
So, thank you so much, everybody.
It was a long, long day of streams for me.
So, actually, well, no, I'll talk about this later.
Oh.
I was gonna mention something, but it's something that I
kind of want to talk about.
During my, during, on Friday.
I feel awkward calling it a debut, so.
Thank you so much for the podcast.
Thank you.
Okie dokie.
Okay, for real now.
For real.
Otsaminto, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Otsaminto, bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.